what's up brother how are you Joe how
you hanging in there
I have not been off of my property more
or less in two weeks so it's crazy to
see another human being
yeah I don't think this is healthy for
us I know this lockdown [ __ ]
everybody's so weirded out he want to
run into people walking dogs like they
don't want the dogs to get close to each
other like hi everyone's across the
street hi and I'm a hugger right
anywhere in California so I'm a hugger
in California and all of my instincts
are wrong everything's all messed up
everyone's confused here's the big
question how long does it take before we
normalize and go back like let's say the
end of July everyone announces we got
this thing locked down we have a viable
treatment it's no different than the flu
they get you this chloroquine with the
z-pak or whatever the current treatment
is yeah when do people start hugging
again what do you mean it's night it's
gonna be crazy I mean I think that the
ideas were also starved for touch yeah
like we're gonna have a a Jubilee like
you've never seen
people are gonna greet each other with
tongues who are almost like just
acquaintance I don't think that's a good
idea
there's still colds and cooties and all
that I know but I think I think
everybody's losing their [ __ ] they
definitely are I've been talking to a
lot of friends that are on the extremely
cautious side let's say that and you
know they're not going anywhere and
they're wearing gloves and masks when
they step outside their house to go do
something the backyard and they put the
glove and mask down and they spray it
with Lysol and they come inside and it's
not healthy and it is also healthy I
mean the idea that we have not been
tested and so long it's good to remember
also that this stuff is live and real
and it has always been live and real and
you know if it was possible to live
without this stuff that would be one
thing but the 75-year nap that we've
been in since 1945 is itself the
greatest threat to all of us right and
and our preparedness is just a wonderful
indicator where you actually get to see
this is the quality of your experts this
is the quality of your leadership this
is what they look like when put under
stress that's true right that is a good
that's a good thing and I'm impressed
with
the medical community I'm impressed with
the people that are recognizing that
this is a huge problem not so impressed
with the administration of a lot of
these hospitals that haven't prepared in
terms of like masks and ventilators and
a lot of these other things not so
impressed with politicians but also it
just seems like everyone like you said
was in this nap state and hadn't really
been tested and really globally no one
had been tested since the pandemic of
1918 like this right 68 which I had I
had the Hong Kong flu and 57 were sort
of the best parallels to this you got
the Hong Kong flu in six I had the Hong
Kong flu and it was sick as a dog
I will San Francisco I was like three
two three four stop it
I think it went from 68 to 72 remember
it oh yeah and I was in San Francisco my
grandma had to come up from LA to care
for me it was it was bad there's like
one of my earliest memories yeah
and so 68 and 57 I think are the best
comparables to this going before we go
back to 1918 and almost nobody remembers
these things like it's very weird many
people that never heard of the kong-kong
flu when I started talking about the
fact that I'd yeah I've a Glee
remembered it until you just said it no
no Mike I'm slightly older than you
right yeah I'm 52 I'm 54 yeah I don't
remember the Hong Kong foe but I do you
know I mean like I don't remember it
personally no but but you as a health
geek are up on these sorts of things and
so you understand the ways in which you
know for example you can have a flu
where the I guess the cytokine storm you
know is you're either the threat from
your immunity your immune system is like
bigger than the virus itself there are
all these various weird things that
happen but I think that this that let's
call it the big nap the big nap is
itself the greatest threat to us and
this is this is bad but it is also a
shot across our bow and in you know this
is what's happening in my mind when I
was on here talking about the to a
nuclei problem of cell an atom we didn't
stop history it's not like we're past
atomic war like we figured that out
we just we just hit the pause button for
a little while we hit snooze yeah the
fear is also that nefarious players will
take this opportunity to erode civil
civil rights to erode civil liberties
and then China to gain power in the US
market to gobble up a lot of stocks
while everything is down and try to
increase their stake in our economy and
try to push it you know
China's got its hands lovingly around
our throat because our elite have been
moving into greater and greater states
of China dependence mm-hmm right and so
and so what the BDSM community refers to
as breath play and I don't like it
migrant plays like you kind of like half
choke somebody yeah how do you know that
what oh you know I went it I went to I
went to MIT and MIT is wildly into BDSM
so many other white wire geeks and and
aspies into BDSM that somebody said lots
of rules
what's an Aspie there's people right
lots of rules they like that they like
they love rules because they're hope
because to do all this stuff safely you
would have to have a huge hierarchy
right of rules and my claim is is that
China is they supply so much of our
stuff we've moved all of our yeah you
know manufacturing base into these crazy
supply chains and we are completely
dependent on a strategic rival and you
know China is very careful if you
remember when they when they hosted the
Olympics to have these amazingly
impressive displays that are always
friendly but what they're really saying
is we have our [ __ ] together and our
system was hackable it was open as long
for example if you have a company that
has a duty to its shareholders they the
directors of the company must do what as
ever whatever is in the best interest of
the shareholders and everything else
doesn't matter then you can have a
situation where a director has to move
things to China because that is in the
best interest of the shareholders even
if it's an absolutely not in the best
interest of the United States this is
what Ralph Comrie who used to head the
sloan Foundation
once said in an address I was at at the
National Academy of Sciences he just
said as a director I am incentivized to
do exactly the wrong thing for the
United States of America so I'm gonna
put one hat on and tell you as an
American we must not move all of this
over to China and then I'm going to put
my directors hat on and I'm gonna vote
to move everything over to China because
I have no choice and so you know in
essence the smart good people all 11 of
them we're always fighting this thing
about you cannot become China dependent
and in during the big nap
there was no way to make this argument
convincingly
you couldn't say look we have a serious
strategic problem by your continuing
moves to bring China in as the solution
to every equation we can't balance and
that that is really the problem is is
that there wasn't any ability to say we
are way too dependent on a strategic
rival you saw this at the beginning of
the pandemic everyone was afraid of what
I don't want to be appear xenophobic I
don't appear like Chicken Little right
and so all of our friends the nutcase is
the marginal weirdoes the supposed
grifters and gadflies are the people who
most got this one right and early and
all the respectable people like Nancy
Pelosi telling people please go to
Chinatown to celebrate the Chinese New
Year bill de blasio of New York saying
despite carnivals get out there let you
know don't lead your lives don't don't
let this thing hold you back these
people need to resign Nancy Pelosi
should resign it's one thing to say we
don't have enough information about this
it's another thing to say take the
information that's coming in disregard
it and get back in there and keep
fueling the economy this is exactly our
leadership class their problem they
think about this in short-term economics
the the long-term implications of us all
sheltering in place
nobody can compute the consequences of
not one person in the world knows what
happens when you run this experiment
yeah it's a new thing right the made in
America argument was always like sort of
frivolous almost xenophobic like why do
you want things made in America what do
you care do you not do not like people
from other countries do you not want
things from other countries it was like
this made of it made in America thing
was like people disregarded it in a lot
of ways but when you realize that all of
our medical supplies like so much of our
electronics so much of all the stuff
that you need to kind of keep things
exactly the way they are it's cheaper to
make it over there because they will
like what we saw with Foxconn where they
put Nets around the building to keep
people from jumping off and the weirdest
thing was people trying to argue that
the suicide rate at Foxconn was
essentially the same as a suicide rate
in the general population
well you ever heard that argument yeah
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
that's where they work there's Nets
around where they work because so many
people where they work jump off the
building to end their life because their
life sucks that bad that they killed
themselves at work do you know rare it
is to kill yourself at work probably
pretty [ __ ] rare you know how common
it is where you have to put Nets around
the building you're like look we're
getting really tired of people going to
the roof and jumping off because it's
the easiest way to kill yourself they're
gonna get more creative yeah the problem
is we are all hooked up to this need for
cheaper products yeah profits when we
can't figure out how to innovate enough
to actually create the juice in our own
system and therefore we have to
rationally say I mean also we've gotten
into this idea of every year we have to
have a newer better piece of electronics
like if you gotta go the rest your life
with an iPhone 11 how much would you
suffer not that much although I would
say that many of us are not that excited
about the next phone that would that
that itself is an antiquated thing right
but what I'm saying is like why can't
they make it so that you can just fix
this yeah you know I mean like who the
[ __ ] fixes their phone you don't fix
your phone you bring not depression-era
thinking it's like why can't things be
sustainable no no I the plants
obsolescence and the need to constantly
update so that you know you're never
it's a tricky problem if you need growth
to power your system then in a weird way
it makes sense not to build the optimal
phone right because if you were to build
the optimal phone and then people
stopped renewing everything your systems
[ __ ] then your system weirdly breaks
down so it makes sense at the level of
the phone that you wouldn't want to do
that but weirdly in aggregate if you
can't start innovative if you can't
figure out how restart innovation in a
big way now you're stuck with either
having to live learn to live in
steady-state which none of us we
Americans have no program for living in
steady-state we need growth that was the
whole point of the embedded growth
obligation idea that it's a fused
throughout every institution every
pension plan assumes growth right right
all right so now we have this problem
where we don't have the growth and we
need the growth and then in a weird way
the planned obsolescence is like fake
growth it means that we're gonna rebuy
our phones even as if they were now
highly innovative so there's like a
weird way in which we become dependent
on nonsense you know
dependent on nonsense is a great way to
put it this is really highlighting that
for a lot of people when people are home
and they're with their families and
they're not travelling especially people
like me and my peers like a lot of my
comedian friends who travel constantly
we're like it's kinda nice to be home
you know everyone sort of relooking it's
just like what it is this life that
we've sort of accepted as this is the
way things are is this really the way
things should be or is this just we just
got caught in a pattern and we're
operating on momentum if the committee
Archimedean force becomes non
dysfunctional we are screwed well that's
not so many
is far away from normal as Canadian I
know it's why I get along with them so
well it's so hard for me to hang out
with regular folk you know that's that
would be rough like if I had to live in
a community of regular people that just
work every day but if you had like a
community of only comedians what would
that look like Oh that'd be fine really
yeah yeah we'd be fine we have that
that's the comedy show comedy story yeah
if the Comedy Store was just locked down
on like a 500 acre piece of property and
there's a bunch of houses on there for
each other
we just entertain each other well half
the fun of comedians is just us hanging
out we would just get together in laugh
well by the way I should just say one of
the great things about moving back to LA
has been your invitations to come hang
with the comedian's at the store what a
great scene I mean you made this point
to me about a renaissance and then I
think I sent you David Burns book about
music the chapter on CBGB and it's
almost an exact map of what CBGB did as
the Harvard of punk to the comedy stores
Oxford of comedy yeah yeah you you've
been to the back bar look that's the
smoke you got me hammered
two times ago and I was just I stumbled
out of that thing that was the best time
I could remember anything well you know
it's great to even when non comedians
like yourself and you know Melissa and
Matt and you know some of their friends
and all these other people come there
and they're around these people they act
freer they're laughing louder they're
making you know more off-color jokes and
everyone's just laughing Oh having fun I
mean that list is the worst you have to
be very careful oh she's hilarious
she's very funny yeah Melissa Chen by
the way shout out shout out to Melissa
by the way what great stuff she's doing
on masks yeah explain that well she's
just she just takes it on herself to ask
the question why don't why don't our
doctors and nurses have masks and so
she's running around trying to figure
out how to connect donors flights
product
whatever she's doing she's heroically
like taking a ton of this on her
shoulders and not I I'm hesitating
because I don't even know what I'm
allowed to say right yeah we don't have
to talk you should she's she's a very
interesting person I'm really glad you
introduced me to her she's fascinating
this like this is a great time to see
what people are actually made out of yes
whose heroic the heroic impulse sure and
and who can keep their [ __ ] together
when things go sideways when things get
western as it were well let me ask you a
question
of all of the presidential candidates
that were in the race like everybody has
dropped out and as well which of them
would you want in a Kovan Tulsi Tulsi
that's by the way that was my answer as
well I don't I didn't want her pop
foreign policy that's one of the reasons
I wasn't like gung-ho and Tulsi I didn't
like some of the stuff about in India
there's some issues about Modi and I
don't want to get into that but if you
asked like who would you want to like
who has that kind of lockdown military
we have to make sense the [ __ ] needs
to leave the room the odd thing is it's
a millennial female of color that I
would immediately want to subordinate to
well she's because she would also be no
[ __ ] she she had the strength to
call out all of the nonsense she was if
she would just say this is unacceptable
what are we doing this is emergency
times we had to suspend these issues we
have to get these things to our doctors
nurses emergency technicians I mean look
I should say that I'm trying to be like
smiley and positive but I am just
burning with rage I cannot those weren't
set up correctly the scale of the screw
up and trying to even understand a
government that I cannot trust as far as
I can throw it to feel contempt for the
Surgeon General of the United States to
say that the World Health Organization
is a danger to world health to say that
the CDC is lying I hate being in a
position where I believe yeah um what
about Tulsi she's she's a person of real
character you know I don't see her like
I see a lot of these people that are
running for president I see them wearing
masks you know I mean I don't even need
to name names but they're doing their
best impression of a politician like a
shitty comedian will do their best
impression of Dave Attell you know
that's the best example that someone
gave me of like the comparison there
there's there's a style of communicating
that a lot of them have adopted to try
to appear and you can tell that they're
coached they're trying to appear
presidential she's just that's who she
is man
I've hung out with her off camera on
camera I've seen her just the way she
communicates with people now I don't
know her down to the bone but what I see
I'm very impressed with and she's
developed her character over two tours
of duty overseas again who volunteers
who takes the stuff on this is the weird
thing because I you know I really before
covered I was in this Bernie yang tossie
mindset which is just what is the
furball that I can shove down the throat
of the DNC to make the party fall apart
under that Hillary Clinton overhang
mm-hmm the weird thing is in an actual
pandemic
I am almost positive that she has the
stuff yeah it may not be her year right
she's only 38 he's only 38 yeah it might
not be her year but but she'll get there
but but how interesting that like when
the [ __ ] hits the fan the person with
the highest number of intersectional
points maybe is actually the person that
you want to lead on merit right but they
don't want her which is even more
because they don't want her because she
can't be bought and sold well that's
it's really simple I think that you know
we need to revisit some stuff which all
of this anger and ferocity that we were
using to stand up to social engineering
invading the mainstream conversation I
believe that kovat proves that it is
deadly mm-hmm that if your top concern
is not appearing xenophobic people will
die because you are functionally
incompetent you've just lost 40 IQ
points for nothing well that was the
initial response to Trump's the idea of
shutting down flights from China people
were furious and they were calling it
racist well the the idea that you can
put a negative sign in front of Donald
Trump and
form an opinion that if he's stupid then
whatever the reverse of what he does is
smart right is itself moronic it's
dangerous it's it's completely
irresponsible and here's the weird thing
and I said this to you on the phone the
other day when we were talking the weird
thing Joe is is that we are the actual
adults in the room
tulsi you me that's a huge problem what
that swapping me in with well that's
what I'm trying to say but you but this
is the problem which I think I get this
actually better than you which is you
have a beautiful life and you recognize
that part of it comes with humility of
not thinking too much of yourself being
self-deprecating all these thing I think
that those are all to your credit it is
also time to lead and if you believe
that you having to break out of whatever
mindset you're in could be the
difference between you know saving
physicians lives and nurses lives you'd
do it you would do it for sure for sure
okay well this thing is the flagship of
pirate radio I mean this is samizdat for
the world and the concept of Sam is that
that that you would have truth that
would circulate underground in the
Soviet Union that would not be like you
are seldom rebroadcast inside of like
MSNBC or CNN except when they're like
going after you
well what's weird is Fox News
rebroadcast me all the time
well because Fox there to sort of
dominant narratives Fox News is the
flagship inside the right-of-center
gated institutional narrative and then
you have all the other organs like MSNBC
CNN NPR BuzzFeed you know whatever these
things are in the left of center gated
institutional narrative very often Fox
will pick up on things that we do if
they stick it in the eye of the left
yeah that's exactly and so the point is
is that they selectively amplify us and
that process of selective amplification
is itself dangerous lot like I get
invited more frequently by Fox and
people and I turn them down because the
narrative inside of like the New York
Times is well he's part of that right
way
thing frequent foxnews contributor Eric
Weinstein oh that's the adjective
occupation name yes
frequent adjective foxnews contributor
my occupation and then my name that game
like if NPR would call and put me on I
would go on Fox but the the they're very
clever game is to make it sound like oh
well you're choosing to go no you guys
are choosing to ignore a lot of what's
changing the culture and they're
therefore the only people who are
willing to ask us on and rebroadcast us
are the people who are angry at the NPR
cnn's MSNBC's well i think they realized
the limitations of their medium i really
do i think that CNBC NBC and MSNBC and
CBS and NBC and ABC they all realize
that they're in this really weird
situation where they have to do these
seven-minute segments interrupted by
commercials they they have a restriction
they can only air at you know but
whatever time of night the show is
supposed to be scheduled and you know
they rely on these internet clips to
sort of carry the show I mean the the
YouTube clips are probably far more
popular than anything they ever released
that's on the air what that that I mean
that their distribution thing is [ __ ]
it's very it's very bizarre and it was
very interesting watching Bill Maher sit
down here he was like I guess this is it
the man cave like yeah good to see you
bill he's like I'm here to grovel and
ask whether you'll come on my show no he
was trying to force me on his show hey
no very little problem he's not a
growler no but he's a strong armor well
what he is is he's caught and he's
caught between two tectonic plates he is
the closest thing we have inside of the
beast in some sense to what we're doing
maybe yeah he's a comic he is a comic
but he's also you know he he's a guy
with real courage yes and he's in a very
tough I think he's in weirdly the
toughest spot of us all well he's a guy
who's on the Left also who thinks that a
lot of the stuff as do as I do and as
you do as well a lot of stuff that's
perpetrated by the people on the left is
not just Dain
but it's it's it empowers the right and
empowers Trump support is it gets people
on the fence to give up and and jump
right and and get welcomed yo I've
stopped being nice to these people it
can't be no it's just you so much
buffoonery it's and it's like it's it's
psychotically dangerous to watch people
continue the buffoonery in life and
death situations yeah yeah no I agree
and Bill's their honor you gonna brush
on have you done I'll do it eventually
I'm sure yeah
the only options that he gave me at gigs
booked I see I I think that it's really
important to use I mean I don't know him
at all but to the extent that that was a
beachhead to connect these two universes
my model of this is that we've got this
traditional legacy world and we've got
this sort of Internet world that hovers
above it and in general the insulating
layer between them is astounding at this
late date the number of things that
happened on the internet that don't
really have any echo inside of the
mainstream is astounding in 2020 and
then you get these arcs that happen
between the two so for example the
famous Sam Harris interaction with Ben
Affleck on Bill Maher show yeah it was
an arcing between these two universes I
was also a guy on steroids that was roid
raging at a guy who actually knows what
he's talking about I mean he was
preparing for Batman okay did the math
on that all right but then that's why he
was so angry but then Kathy Newman and
Jordan Peterson was another arcing where
Kathy was playing the role of Ben
Affleck Jordan Peterson not really know
she what she was doing she was trying to
get away with this same strategy that
she is lazy to generate exactly for this
sort of general boxing and categorizing
them someone's opinions that don't
really represent they're represent their
actual opinions so what you're trying to
say so what you're saying to me Joe is
that I have absolutely no point in my
worth as human beings should never visit
your shows that were saying what you're
trying to say so what I am trying to say
is that in a generalized sense she was
just doing that same old same old yeah
and with with a person who is not
participating I sort of like in the it's
also that
these people that they would victimized
by putting them into these narratives
right that and they're accustomed to
using these patterns these people
traditionally did not have any other way
to respond right there was no internet
clips that were released a letter to the
editor well on page 25 yeah and maybe
they would print a retraction I mean
this is standard standard behavior for
some newspapers and some journalists
right
the unscrupulous ones unfortunately but
this this model doesn't work anymore
because anyone can go on YouTube and
instantly say my time on the Kathy
Newman show this is what went wrong and
this is why she did this and this is
what they told me in the green room and
this is what and then you lay it out
sort of sort of you know here's I mean
let's play with it maybe you're right
maybe you're wrong I don't know my take
on it is that the great thing about we
have we have an ability to do almost
anything we want on YouTube so long as
we don't get shut down let's say that
however you also have this concern that
as long as this world remains gated if
for example you have a closed world of
people who are pretending to have
conversations amongst themselves
discussing the issues and then you have
the institution say we're only going to
deal with the authoritative sources then
the problem is is that if you have a
state of pretend you know LARPing or
kayfabe whatever you want to call it
yeah it's taking place inside the gated
institutional narrative the institutions
are going to predicate their actions on
the official nonsense and whatever we do
on YouTube as long as there is an
insulating layer unless we can actually
lob something into the wall you know
over the walls of the Citadel they will
continue to actually act as if we'd
never said anything we never pointed it
out it's like you're at this kid's magic
show which the musician the magician is
completely incompetent and the lights
are on and you can see all the wires and
trapdoors and the magic show continues
to go on and so you may make the point
well everybody can see that it's
[ __ ] but as long as the institutions
agree to pretend that they believe the
[ __ ] we have a real problem than the
internet that didn't solve that it's
like
the internet might not have solved it
sorry to interrupt I think what it has
done is severely erode the foundation of
it to the point where the trust in it is
just there's no real mainstream anymore
like this idea that the mainstream news
is the mainstream well how is that real
if YouTube videos get more views like if
you if you make a YouTube video and it
gets 5 million views but then something
goes on MSNBC gets 500,000 views yeah
what's mainstream well what is
mainstream now we're talking about
instead of mainstream media I think the
term traditional media is the best way
the same way the term like legacy but
keep going legacies good okay
well look for the longest time people
had to use Morse code right and then
they figured out phones and as Morris
code guys were [ __ ] right what did you
do what you know and then phones were
attached to cords yeah but I don't know
here is there's still phone no but
there's still a function unfortunately
to the so I love the point that you're
making I'm just trying to figure how to
play with it
let's assume if there is no mainstream
left what we're really talking about is
legacy institutional media yeah and the
great danger is that assume that the
mainstream completely exits the building
and it's only you know 10,000 people
trading [ __ ] amongst themselves but
they also control all the institutions
so like you the world gets to keep
reality mm-hm and we the institution's
agree to traffic in [ __ ] you can
make lots of jokes at our expense but
we're also going to be figuring out
whether work in a stock masks or what
our farming policy is or how the US
military should be deployed and where we
should send troops to protect oil fields
and all these kind of things and that's
what's concerning me is is that a lot of
us are settling for being right and
having them look like idiots and their
point is okay fine we'll continue on
we'll look like idiots but we also still
control the levers so with legacy media
your your assertion is that legacy media
has a much more impactful presence in
terms of foreign policy in terms of
dealing with
pandemic the response sings along those
lines let's play with it and see where
it goes okay if you think about
Wikipedia Wikipedia might have a rule
that says we allow we don't do original
research so please link to authoritative
sources and you say okay great what are
authoritative sources yeah so now the
authoritative source is the CDC or the
WH o or the Surgeon General or the New
York Times or CNN or MSNBC like if you
have this but is n MSNBC like if someone
just goes on on the air and let's have a
little something see is that an
authoritative source or wouldn't it be
like an expert in Hell to someone who's
gone over peer-reviewed studies someone
who is well who's the Surgeon General
right now I don't know CDC is that red
field I don't know I'm sure he's a
competent physician I also think that
there's a whole thing about pretending
that masks don't work masks don't work
in the general population please don't
buy them our health care people need
them there's our they're tiny
well that's what they've been saying
right and so the issue is that you have
some piece of nonsense so the the
original piece of nonsense because the
California is now changing their
recommendation and saying if you're
going out in public it's not just
nonsense its deadly nonsense it's deadly
physician killing nonsense I mean I'm
trying smiles everyone smiles yeah yeah
I mean what we have is a situation in
which we knew that the masks and
personal protective equipment supplies
are wildly off to say nothing of
ventilators and ICU beds and now what do
we do about it so we have rules like
please don't bring masks to work because
it scares the patients or please don't
wear homemade masks because they might
actually be more germ filled or virus
filled so you're back propagating what
you wish to be true to get the action
that you're looking for what we have is
a prisoner's dilemma or if everybody
runs and buys up masks ooh like the
people we need to be protected most are
the heroes who are actually dealing with
you know multiple
patience and taking huge amounts of
viral load so there's no question in my
mind that those those are the people
that is a society if you would level
with us like there's a speech to give
which would go like this you know my
fellow Americans as readiness are I am
forced to tender my resignation
effective of Friday this week I have
failed to heed many of the warnings in
our academic literature because our
reserves are severely depleted it is
imperative that we not suffer further
loss of life and therefore I am forced
to make an unusual request having failed
you I'm asking everyone who stockpiled
masks for personal use to think about
doing something sacrificial for the good
of us all our heroes are currently
exposed to the coronavirus and taking
huge amounts of viral load and I'm
asking you to donate any unused masks
that you have to this population as we
are desperately trying to replenish our
stocks please continue to shelter in
place and recognize that the benefit to
you is minor and the benefit to us all
is major and this will be following your
heroic impulse to bring us back together
as a nation first of all is there a
readiness azar no okay second of all no
one's gonna say that they're never gonna
admit that if they're gonna say we are
tell justing
I know Cour we're adjusting or firing
the Dacians basin of all new no Joe I am
I'm gonna be completely unreasonable
I know I have this mode where I just I
can become completely unreasonable
go ahead this is if that's where we are
then it's time to ruble revolt how I
don't know well we need people's if it's
civil civil disobedience like to put our
health care people I mean I have not
been off my property
for weeks the reason I'm here in part is
to do what little I can and is very
little to support the people who we who
are our literal heroes our
life-and-death putting their cell
themselves in harm's way the idea of how
hospital administrators abusing our
physicians and nurses makes me
apoplectic with rage the fact that these
people are told that they can't talk to
the press and they write to me and
they're their family and the children
write to me my mother was asked to do
this my uncle works in a prison he's not
allowed to wear masks he's not allowed
to bring a mask I send a mask blah blah
blah yeah there's a lot of those stories
okay what the hell is wrong it is time
for these people to resign and it is
time for us to remember that we have the
ability to turn over our own government
this is we are so unprepared as a nation
and we have been sold out for so long by
our self-appointed leadership class who
nobody wants that we either remember who
we are and how this game is played I
mean this is like this is a pre-war
footing and this can easily lead to war
the transmission mechanism is you have
everybody stay indoors because you're
worried about deaths of accountability
which is you know I don't think they're
worried about the number of deaths I
think they're worried about deaths that
the results from triage and that would
result in career-ending action yeah this
is what you were saying on the phone do
you think that's really what's bothering
them yes and then but if we all have to
stay home while they replenish our
supplies then the economy goes into
recession and recession can become
depression depressions lead to armed
conflict in armed conflict leads to war
that would be a transmission mechanism
from these stupid masks to stop
something that nobody can handle and my
it here's the thing
we are coming up on Passover and we Jews
have a tradition that I wish everybody
had which is that we read one stupid
story
every goddamn year just to drill it into
your head to make sure it's always fresh
and this is when it's time to leave when
it's time to change don't wait for the
bread to rise this is what I say to
every Jewish person like you're sitting
around waiting for the bread to rise
because they all know the story which is
you eat the goddamn matzah because the
people who waited for the bread to rise
are no longer with us and their
descendants are no longer with us
and it is time to revolt this leadership
class is unworkable the reason that you
and I both came to the word tulsi
instantly I don't think you took much
deliberation is because tulsi would know
what to do well she's also the least
encumbered yeah she's at least burdened
by
everybody in the system hates her yeah
you know in the whole point where she
would put heads on pikes yeah this is
the moment for heads on pikes and it's
important it's not a vengeance thing the
the importance is what is the cost to
you killing people by failing to heed
the academic literature if a supply was
was depleted and you didn't replenish it
what is the cost to you
well there's lessons in how other
countries have viewed this and how they
chose to act particularly South Korea
right South Korea acted quicker smaller
population than us but a much more
impact to the virus they shut things
down very quickly yeah yeah Singapore
I don't know how Singapore very very
interesting I think that they you know
they use surveillance and tracking and
you know making sure that they visited
anybody was known I mean they had a
different system and as people who like
you and me who loved our civil liberties
I believe that in part Singapore's
draconian society lives off of things
that only we can do due to our freedom
so you have to realize that freedom is
itself an export and one of the great
dangers is is that China has been
exporting the benefits of freedom from
the United States into an authoritarian
system so that they get the benefits of
both worlds they get the benefits of our
middle finger which I think is the
secret of American innovation and they
get the benefits of authoritarianism
where they can do things that we can't
because they can order people to do the
unconscionable so my feeling is I'm on
Team civil liberties and team civil
liberties has to be somewhat
nationalistic more militaristic more
commanding control like who would you
take orders from so in a lot of fields
I'd take orders from you you're the big
dog in this space you know and to the
extent that you wanted to coordinate
something I would use my channel I would
subordinate to you and I would want
sometimes people disobey to me if I have
if I was taking a lead on something
important when we have this fear of
leadership because we're all so
individualistic that we never want to
take an order like whenever I'm training
a new assistant or something what am i
always
best practices is can I get you coffee
you know it's very important to show
that the ability to ask to serve
somebody else and the ability to lead
are tied you have to be a follower to be
a leader and a leader to be a follower
you can't you shouldn't be one of the
other we need right now a more war we
need more of a war footing we need a war
president we need we need war senators
we need people of this mentality because
the nap is coming to an end and I do
think Nancy Pelosi needs to resign and
Bill DeBlasio needs to resign I think
that this administration you know made
some good moves and fumbled the ball and
I believe that past administration's
made some good moves and fumbled the
ball and the imperative is to stop back
propagating what you want to have what
you want us to do like defeat a
prisoner's dilemma and come up with a
lie that would cause us to act selfishly
rationally like if you tell me that a
mask is actually more dangerous in my
hands because it becomes germ filled
then the idea is like oh okay so I guess
I won't use the mask well yeah because
you lied to me
and the idea is that that's what you're
trying to do your finger you're trying
to say what would need to be true to get
you to do what I want I don't understand
what you're saying about these masks
what are you saying so if I say for
example let's imagine that I don't want
to put seat belts in cars okay and I say
you know Joe a seat belt could trap you
should your car go into the water off of
a bridge you could in fact die from the
seat belt because you'd become entangled
it would not be able to save yourself
the right but the problem with that
analogy is seat belts actually do save
lives on but is it is it possible that
they're just acting poorly with this
mask thing but that masks actually can
contain a lot of viruses and they can
see bones can kill you but do you
believe that's what I'm trying to do I'm
trying to say it as a related great
problem let's talk about everybody who
gets sick and dies from contaminated
masks everybody who gets sick and dies
from I feel a false feeling of safety
let's just go through a huge list about
every time saying I see the intervention
and now the idea is think about all the
lives saved because of masks both in
terms of transmission which I don't
coffin you a coffin
masks or in terms of I don't breathe in
either aerosolized or droplets whatever
blah blah blah and now the two are real
but you're focusing on like the seatbelt
deaths of entanglement right because you
actually have a covert agenda and like
and you would I think their covert
agendas oh I don't know exactly but if
you if I had to speculate I go like it
go like this one were terrified of
triage deaths deaths that occurred
simply because we didn't have enough
resources that were mandated to be
stockpiled or talked about in the
literature that's one thing there's
liability then there's liability which
is oh we were following the Surgeon
General's recommendation at the time now
somebody suddenly found you know like
all the masks in the world I think that
the Surgeon General would suddenly say
the science has become conclusive mmm
because there would no longer be a worry
about liability you would just get those
masks that people you'd get the masks to
the people who need them and then you'd
stop transmission you'd slow transitions
transmissions by you think there's also
a lot of just figuring it out as they go
along what's going on there is figuring
this out as it goes along as regards to
masks I believe that everybody knows
that masks save lives on balance they
know that the people who need the most
have very weird rules there's this whole
thing about the states versus the
federal government there's this issue
about price gouging and price mechanisms
there are all sorts of things stopping
the mask problem from being sorted out
in it one of which is the number of
masks that are produced in China and the
fact that we may have sent masks and
personal protective equipment to China
so there's a huge issue of
accountability and responsibility and
that we're back propagating our response
how much are we quarantine and how much
would we lock down what are we saying
about about what why the physicians are
being told not to wear masks when
they're seeing patients I mean I'm
talking about deadly nonsense deadly
structural nonsense and if people like
you and me don't call this out using
like these
channels that we have then the the
narrative just stands and so partially
what we're doing is a parallel
sense-making operation to the standard
media which is uh Twitter said we will
now be removing tweets if you contradict
official authoritative health sources so
that's just what I did
Surgeon General's lying CDC's lying wh o
is lying come at me do you think they're
lying yes but what why do you think
they're lying well give me a specific
example why you feel like they're lying
well for example you saw this
interaction with the was it Hong Kong TV
asking about the wh Oh about Taiwan yeah
that was insane
well explain that because it's [ __ ]
and saying it was insane to watch first
of all he pretended the head of the
w-h-o pretended he didn't hear them and
then he had them say it again first of
all he moves like yes you can see his
hand yes I go to cut off the connection
he hung up he said I couldn't hear she's
okay I'll repeat the question he's like
no let's go on to the next one
well why would he want to go to the next
one if he didn't hear it come on yeah I
don't even have here's the point we are
so afraid to explain what he did to
people that don't know because people
are listening here and there was asked
about the Taiwanese response yes to the
covet epidemic and he didn't want to say
Taiwan because China claims that Taiwan
is part of China and because China
exercises so much influence over the
whu-oh he wanted to say some very
general thing which is like I think all
provinces of China have been doing an
excellent yeah that's a different
country Taiwan because there's a dispute
so what do you think China's most
interested in China PTIN the People's
Republic of China the Communist China
Communist Chinese want no recognition of
their existing something called Taiwan
and why does the World Health
Organization give in to that well how do
how do different nations get control of
things you know we have influence at the
UN and we've caused the UN to do things
that are America centric
you know other countries have influence
and you do this by being on particular
committees rotating directorships who
pays the cost I don't know how the w-h-o
seems to be so enmeshed with China and I
don't want to a pine about these things
because I want to keep my voice right
but it spoke volumes to watch that guy
do that and do that little dance try to
avoid saying time while my entire life
looks like that interviewed I mean I
hate to say it this way but my
relationship with Authority and my big
critique is is that this is the generic
expectation across almost all
institutions now they are all serving
bizarre goals because growth is what
gave us our independence and when we
became less innovative and we or the
innovations dried up and we couldn't
grow our way into new things the number
of people who could use their middle
finger effectively and say I'm steering
this at this organization to do the
right thing and then this is my bet and
we're gonna go forward those people as a
class were removed if you think about
like what do you do with Churchill when
there isn't a world war two to win it's
very uncomfortable like what would he
open a drycleaner we don't know you have
you have special people who really only
shine when there's an emergency there's
a guy named Jay Prakash and Orion in
India was very important he was one of
the sort of founding fathers of modern
India and after India Indian
independence was achieved lots of the
people who'd been founding fathers went
to the next phase where they became like
they enriched themselves they did
standard political things to gain power
in the system he was the one guy who
sort of stayed true to the revolutionary
spirit and bizarrely when Indira Gandhi
created a state of emergency which was a
disaster in India
the people said well who can we turn to
in a dark time and oddly I guess Prakash
means light so there was this phrase
like in the darkness there is one light
Jai Prakash driver - hi Prakash they
turned to the one guy who'd become the
patron saint of
causes because he never broke faith with
the revolutionary spirit and he's get he
gets called up once but he's incredibly
important because everybody knows in a
dark time who they can trust right
that's a very important parallel to
where we are now who are the break glass
in case of emergency people yeah when
you when you watch the people that are
talking in these presidential addresses
there's none of those I don't see any
break glass I mean this foul Qi guy is
obviously an expert in diseases and he's
a doctor and he's trying to do his best
to lay out the ground rules of what we
need to do and what this looks like over
the next couple of months but but it's
like Jaco willing you know like Jaco is
not telling you don't worry you don't
have to change your routine you can get
up at 9:30 just do a little bit just a
little bit there's like discipline
equals freedom I'm up at 4:30 what are
you doing in bed it's time for
discipline well because he's a military
guy and military people don't have any
room for [ __ ] they don't even some
military people's love know people like
seals they don't have any room for fluff
well because you have to be able to
perform well okay so then in that
situation so [ __ ] your feelings get up
at 4:30 that's that's how they feel
that's what I'm trying to sell those you
can just do a little bit and that's
great that's great
you guys are enforcing mediocrity but
that's and that's what I'm trying to get
at which is yeah we have a situation
where we know if you have two trainers
and one of them is doing that don't
worry and the other want to say not
gonna lie to you you're gonna be sore
you're gonna be miserable this isn't
gonna be fun
which do you choose some people will go
with the former yeah they like to stay
fat it's a lot of that out there okay
mediocrity is a very comforting thing I
hear you yeah it's [ __ ] look it's
hard it's hard to be that 4:30 in the
morning guy some days that alarm goes
off he's got to be like [ __ ] this man
well you know that Jocko doesn't live
that 24/7 yes he does
no he may live it he may live it 18 six
nobody lives at 20 Lee you remember that
thing he did about the cake
at a birthday party there was a
delicious piece of cake in front of me I
struggled to come to I succumb to
temptation yeah but I'm telling you man
that doesn't even mean anything that
goes through that [ __ ] blast furnace
of a bomb but I'm saying
nobody's 24/7 on the table he's a fake
weakness yeah he'll give in to a
4-minute weakness yes super mortal like
they're disappearing to make you sort of
commiserate with him he's appearing that
oh I have some feelings too I eat cake
yeah well it doesn't tell you see you
probably went down to his [ __ ]
dungeon basement every cake did squats
for an hour look I believe that there's
people that are really that guy yeah
he's one of those those people he's
really that guy he's that guy all the
time I spent a lot of time with Jocko
okay he's that guy but that's because
he's then I won't see okay I want but I
want one of those people right now
important right now yeah those guys are
important and we have to clean out these
up this class of people that put up with
each other it's like the reason they put
up with each other and they don't like
indict each other or sue each other in
each other is is that they're all the
same you know and that was the key skill
for between 35 and 50 years which is
knowing what not to say to upset the
institutional applica well that is
politics and that's one of the things
that disgust people about it and that's
one of the things that one of the
reasons why Donald Trump actually got
into office yes people looked at him as
an antidote I mean that's that's right
clean up the swamp drain the swamp
that's him well that's what they thought
they thought this is maybe she might
bring in his own swamp but he was
against their swamp exactly yeah exactly
and then Bernie Sanders has his own kind
of swamp he's got a different kind of
swamp you know everyone's got their own
swamp it's like what what is your
particular pattern that you would like
to push you know what has got you to the
dance you know sorry I'm laughing but
Barry Weiss was sitting here she's just
like had so Joe what do you think you'll
vote for and then you called me up you
like Eric what did I just do I think you
might have just swung the election
well the wrong way or the right way
old thing look the Joe Biden being the
main guy is the only reason why they
went after Bernie Sanders and went after
me I mean the whole idea was just to
reinforce the idea that Bernie Sanders
is making poor choices by connecting to
him to someone who says [ __ ] up things
when he's trying to be funny yeah you
know and you put it in print with some
quotations behind it in like wow this
guy's awful you know everything out of
context is awful and what they're trying
to do without a doubt is the same thing
we're talking about the guy who's
willing to dance with them which is Joe
Biden the guy who's the the professional
politician which they don't give a [ __ ]
if he can barely talk they don't give a
[ __ ] if he forgets what he's saying
halfway in the conversation but this is
the whole thing about the gated
institutional narratives age the key
issue and I learned this one I used to
do immigration stuff in Washington
during the 90s I learned this concept of
steady hands this is like one of the
most terrifying phrases ever so I told
you I think at some point that in New
York whenever people are deciding to do
a bad thing to screw people over they
always use the phrase it's a beautiful
thing meaning that you can extract money
from people who have noticed no say in
the matter in Washington his financial
circles are yeah yeah
New York financed so whenever you hear
the phrase it's a beautiful thing it
means somebody is being raped - right
yeah in Washington the phrase that I
learned to fear is steady hands he's a
pair of steady hands that means you can
count on him to do the wrong thing in an
emergency to keep everybody on the
inside okay and there's like a separate
system for promoting the people who do
the wrong thing and making sure because
everybody inside is super dependent on
somebody burning all of their
credibility in public steady hands oh
yeah me that's the main hope of this
free information society that all of
these disgusting practices these legacy
practices can I supposed well here's the
weird thing
when Amy Klobuchar dropped out I was
like a baby boomer born in the let me
say 61 something like that every one
remaining was born in the 1940s
Elizabeth Warren was the youngest then
you had like Mike Bloomberg Bernie
Sanders Joe
in Donald Trump everyone was like born
between 41 and 49 now all of those
people would be the oldest president all
of them the oldest president added
inauguration like we've lost our mind
this is normal to us this isn't really
commented upon that you would have five
four five septuagenarians vying for the
presidency of the United States it's
pretty crazy but we just leave the
evidence is the clearest with Joe Biden
right yeah because he's showing actual
real deterioration but we've seen
deterioration from Trump particularly
earlier in the first year or two of his
term needs some spectacular videos of
him falling apart where he can couldn't
enunciate words he grant couldn't say
words correctly while he's speaking to
the country his tongue was like swollen
in his throat it was very strange right
but people think of that is maybe a
substance issue like he goes up and he
goes down and sometimes he catches it on
the wrong part of the wave and that's
when he's in front of the camera and he
you know he struggles through it but he
literally can't pronounce words but then
he'll bounce back and they'll be fine
Joe Biden's not bouncing back you know
whether he has an aversion to the same
sort of supplements that Donald's using
I don't know I don't know what's going
on yes here's these episodes in
consistent sometimes he seems fine and
then sometimes he seems like he's
completely lost and you know I learned
about this it was very uncomfortable for
me I was watching stefan molyneux and
mike Tsarevich going on and on about
Hillary's health mmm-hmm and I was just
thinking these guys are actually weirdly
making sense on this topic and I've
never really interacted with stefan
molyneux at all and it sort of scares me
I don't really want him in my life but
didn't mean that he wasn't right and he
wasn't being courageous and saying it
and then when Donna Brazile I think came
out later and said yeah there were real
concerns about Hillary's health all
along well she was fainting yeah
wherever you lose consciousness that's a
good we don't know what it was that she
was doing but what I'm
trying to get at would be that we are
dependent on these people that we are
told are trolls as the free people and I
remember Orwell talking about the
proletariat where the proletariat was
weirdly free and the central people were
the ones who had no freedom I saw this
also in the fall of the Soviet Union I
had family in Moscow and Kiev and in
Chernov see that we discovered right at
the end of the Soviet Union and I went
over the visit and I remember preparing
for that visit I called up these people
and Chernov see right near Moldova and
the extreme west of the Ukraine and I
said you know is that a speech in like
hello and I hear the voice and the other
end of the phone was like the time when
long-distance phone calls were still
romantic and they hear Shalom welcome
and I'm realizing that these are young
people are still speaking Yiddish they
don't give a [ __ ] about anything because
they're not important they're not in
Moscow they're not in st. Petersburg
they're on the periphery and there's a
measure of freedom that comes from just
not being central and right you can
communicate freely and you can think
freely is anyone in legacy meeting media
talking openly on any of these shows
about Biden's deterioration I don't know
you know Tucker Carlson is another
person to watch who is freer he's free
of Fox he's able to go against Fox
yeah I'm looking at Greg Gutfeld I don't
know what Greg has been saying but there
are a small number of interesting people
who are still housed inside of the of
the belly of the beast and I don't know
if you hear my heard my theory about the
rebel end of corporate law corporate end
of rebel no so you and I I think would
be sort of well at least I'm wearing a
jacket I would be the corporate end of
rebel okay yeah you might be the rebel
end of rebel I don't know you're you're
faking being the rebel in that you're
pretty sick yeah what am i payin what
well look at all to be in the rebel and
of rebel those tattoos obviously wash
off and you put you just apply them
every day but the Corp the rebel end of
corporate would be like Barry Weiss okay
yeah right so she's she's in the belly
of the beast but she's pushing the edge
Bill Maher would
would straddle corporate end of rebel
rebel end of corporate unclear hmm
right and so there is an important
partnership across this if you think
about you remember the film Inglourious
Basterds did you like that well sure
loved okay lieutenant aldo rey is this
interface between regular army and the
psychotic jews who will kill Nazis given
any opportunity and you need people who
interface between like the bad boys and
the regular units and these are
incredibly important what is the plural
of nexus necks i i don't know we got
into trouble the first time with octopus
octopi
no it's actually octopus the the
recommended one is octopi DS spelled
spelled octopodes really yeah whoa but
I've seen octopi yeah what people people
use awk
they use octopuses octopi they're this
plural form of Nexus is Nexus or Nexus
okay oh boy Jaime with the win how weird
that it's either or that it could just
be Nexus the plural form of Nexus is
that makes sense I guess so these Nexus
yes are used to it are incredibly
important and we have to keep them up
and I'm worried about the corporate or
the rebel end of corporate because these
corporations are starting to realize
that their need for kayfabe is just far
exceeding kayfabe kayfabe kayfabe is
carnival speak for the word fake and
when catch wrestling devolved into
professional wrestling you know about
all that that's very interesting yeah
that's that's a weird well that's
obscure to catch wrestling no carnival
wrestling actually Jamie could you bring
up the word kayfabe in Weinstein can you
name any people that were involved in
catch wrestling the real catch wrestling
how far do you go with this well there
you know farmer Burns was farmer Burns
farmer burn no famous catch wrestling
guy used to do a hangman's drop his neck
was so strong
new surround it and drop six feet and
hang there so when by the way if you
want to read a great book on
professional wrestling I would highly
recommend the book ringside which talks
about the evolution so what I call KK
fabrication okay is the transition of
something that is usually has twin
attributes is very dangerous and very
boring so old-style wrestling was
incredibly dangerous I mean people would
you know be crippled from about so as a
result they would often just like circle
each other and not really engage and
like wars like this mostly war is
extremely boring and then you know
obviously can be quite deadly
so in order to routinize these things we
create kayfabe which is the system of
stratified lies that professional
wrestling is under graded by so you you
know what do you know what a worked
shoot is yes okay
what's a work to shoot well a shoot is
an actual fight and a worked shoot like
a work is a fake fight right so like if
two guys were pretending to fight and
there was there's actually there was an
issue I should so just to lay this all
out in Japan there there's an extremely
admiration for professional wrestling
and professional wrestlers would get
into mixed martial arts and they would
get into mixed martial arts with varying
levels of actual commitment so some of
them would get into mixed martial arts
and have fake fights this is like pride
yes exactly pride and some of pride
actually was founded by Hicks and Gracie
who was as legit as a man has ever lived
and Takata who was a famous professional
wrestler and Hickson [ __ ] up Takata in
a real fight he only would have real
fight who was the Gracie killer who came
out of Japan
that's Sakuraba oh sorry yeah Sakuraba
he well he's a phenomenal catch wrestler
right anyway I don't want to blow you of
course his his he came from
I believe Karl Gotch and Billy Costello
and I think that's the name of the
gentleman there was a bunch of people
who taught him catch wrestling so his
style was submission oriented catch
wrestling he had he had like both like
he you know he was involved in
professional wrestling as well but he
was a legit fighter anyway the point was
there was a weird blurring of the lines
and there were some fights like Mark
Coleman had a fight with Takata
where it was really clear that Mark
Coleman got paid to take a dive because
Mark Coleman should have smashed that
dude and he gets caught his heel hook he
doesn't tap he's gonna tap then he winds
up tapping it was like whoa and he he
tap but everyone watching that knows
fighting was like get the [ __ ] out of
here what is happening here oh my god
it's a fake fight and it could have been
a Content so there was fake fights mixed
in with real fights right it was pretty
common pretty common we decide and this
is what happened in the transition in
the early 20th century between catch
wrestling and professional wrestling is
that you you start doping reality with
fakeness and the thing I was asking
about the work shoot it has to do with
the layering of nonsense and reality so
the idea is that you have something
which is ostensibly fake then you have a
breaking of kayfabe ostensibly which is
the chute on top of the expected work
but a work shoot is tertiary in that the
shoot is in self fake and so work shoot
is a tertiary deception it's a fake
fight that appears real it's a fake real
fight that appears to break out of a
fake thing that is pretending to know
maybe it's quaternary you know the brain
can't go much beyond four levels of lies
right and so you had a famous storyline
I can't remember who it was where a
wrestler was apparently supposedly
having an affair with another wrestlers
wife and that was the storyline so the
people who write those these things are
called Booker's so the Booker's had come
up with this storyline and then the
affair became real because the brain
couldn't sort of manage all of the
deception sometimes you so the two
people actually gather
because they were supposed to hang out
and pretend right now like let's just do
this [ __ ] right and so you know oddly I
was fascinated by the moment where Vince
McMahon declared I think to the New
Jersey sporting commission he made this
unbelievable Ike one of the great
moments in the 20th century I think he
realized that he was gonna be taxed into
oblivion and so we had a choice should
he get should he pay this tax or do
something really bold and he went in
front of them he said you realize that
everything we do is fake
now that could have completely toppled
the wrestling world the admission that
there was no reality to this was a
potential death blow so he said this is
all staged all the fights are nothing
that the winners are known in advance
you can't tax us because we aren't
actually a sport and you don't have any
jurisdiction over us and then it turned
out nobody cared right and so the
interesting thing is that the youth used
to have this concept of ass mark a mark
as somebody who doesn't know they're
being conned a smart mark or smart is
somebody who knows that they're being
conned and still continues to play so in
some sense it was the bet that you could
take all the marks and turn them into
smarts and the business empire would
continue and you wouldn't have to pay
the tax so I was hanging out as what
does with Hulk Hogan and I was trying to
check whether or not this was true and
he said to me Eric you realized who came
up with that strategy me so I was like
what he says yeah I was the one who said
that we should do you believe him I
don't know it's hard to tell well that's
the whole point okay yeah that's where
it gets weird did you ever see the
interview where John Stossel is accusing
a professional wrestler of it being fake
so he decided to smack him in the head
and ask him if that was fake it's really
horrific because he dropped he ruptured
his eardrum means this is an enormous
man I forget the guy it ruined the guy's
career the guy who is the wrestler but
he he hits him with an open hand I mean
it's an enormous Oh full blast hits him
on the head with his this open hand and
drops him he goes was that fake
who was that fake get up [ __ ] and he
goes that fake and he hits him again and
drops him again was that fake
well okay let's talk about this I don't
think professional wrestling is fake
what the [ __ ] are you saying well I know
what you're saying yeah yeah I mean
these guys this is it this is the guy
well play it so we can hear what he's
saying okay we'll get we'll get into
trouble here with YouTube but he hits
him in the side of the head and then he
hits him again it's dr. D I think dr.
death or something that [ __ ] him up
right is that him right there it is that
the guy now Jesus Christ time is a cruel
[ __ ] is that the same guy is that him
Jesus Christ yeah legendary wrestler
bounty hunter and author of don't call
me fake dr. David Schultz goes into
detail about the fashion arrests missed
twenty twenty incident where he slapped
John Stossel
look he's got a t-shirt on it about it
and everything Jesus Christ it's his
whole life now yeah well that's his it's
his moment it's not fake
no it means artist rated it's the
results are known in advance the death
rate of those guys is like nothing else
you'd have to look like wingsuit flyers
to see people who died at the level that
professional wrestlers do that the
punishment that they take and weirdly
the skill level I Hulk Hogan put me in a
headlock why did you let him do that
did you ever see what he did to Richard
Belzer oh look I'm sorry I know that
he's said and done bad things but there
is so much love that comes pouring out
of Hulk Hogan and I agree brother he's a
great guy but he put Belzer sleep on his
television show and Belzer fell him
bounced his head off the ground Hulk
Hulk had me in a headlock and I know
that if that guy had so much as sneezed
my head would have just popped off of my
trunk right I mean that guy's a beast
he's a huge man he's a huge man yeah you
know he's lost like four inches of
height because of all his back surgeries
yeah yeah all right I first met him like
way way way back in the day I ran into
him I didn't meet him meet him I just
ran into him on the street in Beverly
Hills I was like holy [ __ ]
and then I interviewed him for Spike TV
back in the day when Spike TV was
they were doing professional wrestling
on Spike TV and they wanted to me to
interview him while I was doing the UFC
so I interviewing we had a fun time
together but he was considerably smaller
it was really interesting it's like that
was just oh there's Belser so you put
Bowser and what we would call a power
guillotine and look Bowser's out cold
right here right watch the left arm
there it is alcohol so why'd she just
dropped some that could have killed him
that part right there where he falls and
he bangs his head off the ground like he
just dropped him like he was on a padded
mat or something like that you really
should never do that to someone but they
don't worry about their self because
they put themselves into so much danger
thing yeah I mean these guys are the
punishment kings of the world yeah and
they're extremophiles in that sense now
what what my belief is is that we are
it's real in the sense that the injuries
the death rate skill levels and most of
those guys could really fight they may
not be UFC level fighters but they Cal
ah'd of them come out of you know
wrestling backgrounds yes like
legitimate a lot of our very very tough
so in I think what was it in 2013 or 11
Jon Brockman asked the question what's
the scientific theory that nobody knows
that would make the biggest impact in
people's cognitive toolkit and I just
been allowed to answer this question
along with like actual legitimate people
and so I was kind of like being very
protective and my wife said you know you
could give a lot of answers that
question but that's not the one you want
to give Duke a Fabe like I had this
theory that kayfabe was the most
important psychological theory that
nobody really appreciated that in some
sense professional wrestling is
lightyears ahead and understanding how
the human mind actually works because of
the issues of that deception and so I
wrote up kayfabe which is going to
determine Wars and presidential
elections and then sure enough Donald
Trump comes directly out of WWE like he
really understands if you look at that
fight with Vince McMahon yeah Donald
Trump into its professional wrestling
and it is a superpower
Jamie can I ask you to bring up
Weinstein in kayfabe and see if 2011
what scientific concept would improve
everybody's cognitive toolkit Eric
Weinstein so I thought it was going to
be thrown out and in turn in fact that
turned out to be a very prophetic
prophetic essay well for sure once Trump
got into office I mean that is an
excellent point of what he does is that
there's a part of his appeal is that
he's speaking in he's he's like he's
hitting a certain frequency that
provides comfort and it narrows the
boundaries of what's possible and puts
things into some very digestible form
that morons love you know I'm talking
about I'm not saying that all people
that are Trump supporters are morons
there's people that support him
economically but there's a lot of people
that are morons that like him because
he's talking in this frequency he's he's
there's a narrow band he's not gonna say
anything crazy
that's like self-deprecating or
introspective or he's not going to
prepare you for the the great beyond or
you know include you in his concerns for
the demise of civilization and Western
values not that's not in him right right
he's got a bandwidth he's got a very
narrow band and inside that band he's
the king
ratings are tremendous tremendous
everyone's doing a great job we're doing
a great job he says these things that
key they reinforced this sort of
pro-wrestling sort of vibration somewhat
I I have to admit that I don't meet many
morons at all should come to Comedy
Store more often let's back up I'll
bring you out some more oh oh sure Joe
you don't even believe that I think that
in general people when they are given no
choice at all express themselves
moronically when they're given no choice
at all yeah I I want a choice of an
actual president that's viable I don't
have one so then you're gonna ask me
well which which of the non-viable
people do you like best well this is the
this is the real issue with the
Democratic Party they've essentially
made us all morons
yeah with this Joe Biden thing they
really have morons who do we need I mean
I never vote for that guy I can't vote
for him I can't vote for him I can't
vote for Trump there I'd rather vote for
Trump than him I don't think he could
handle anything I mean you're relying
entirely on his cabinet like we want to
talk about a an individual leader that
can communicate he can't do that and we
don't even know what the [ __ ] he's gonna
be like after a year in office the
pressure of being the president United
States is something that no one has ever
prepared for right the only one who
seems to be fine with it is Trump
oddly enough I mean he hasn't seemed to
be aging at all or any sort of decline
you know Obama like almost immediately
started looking older yeah George w
almost immediately Scott I think that
this is not a change in Trump like Trump
in a weird way it's just always been
this right performative you know like a
fake alpha right he still plays golf all
the time like isn't switched up monster
I mean I'm sure he switched it up a
little bit because of the pandemic
because he's apparently a germaphobe
which is hilarious but this is this
could be his demise you know he isn't
that kind of hilarious yeah that might
be what does him in the guys always been
worried about germs apparently how does
that work with his active
extracurricular life I don't know I
guess he wears condoms I wouldn't have
Chyna I wouldn't have imagined stormy
Daniels would be the person that he
would have chosen first then it's just
it's very strange there's a hot lady
back in the day well it's not question
of that it's just that she was also an
active one yeah if your if your key
issue is transmission I mean I'm not
judging anybody I'm just saying as a as
a vector of communication yeah that's
true
that's a good question of course the
porn industry weirdly has very high
health standards at one level because it
would have to right maybe that's his
rationale that they're tested yeah
that's interesting so I had Ashley
Matthews on my program and I she was you
know talking to me about cuz that was
actually the woman behind Riley Reid Wow
okay and how hilarious is that it's like
that's her pro-wrestling name yeah
well and I don't know that she'd used
her name fully until we were talking and
I said that I really want it didn't want
to interview Riley read I wanted to
interview Ashley Matthews
how'd that go what she was good I mean
she it was a bit of a mismatch in but
she is polite and sweet to a fault she's
trying to be thoughtful I'd really
admire her courage she doesn't want body
body augmentation so she's got a
non-classical porn body she had I chose
to do a transom because it was erotic ly
interesting to her even though she was
told that it would kill her brand she
doesn't necessarily sometimes she shaves
her body here sometimes she doesn't
okay so there's a lot of what she does
that I think is incredibly admirable and
I got to know of her because she came to
a show that I did with ben shapiro and
sam harris in san francisco and she was
tweeting out that she was a huge Sam
Harris fan and then I saw something she
did where she was talking about it was
impossible for her to get banking and
regular services as a pornographic
actress and thank you yeah there's like
a remember operation choke point no
operation choke point was I think in a
Bhama era Department of Justice
initiative to try to make it very
difficult to engage in legal occupations
like payday lending and things or porn
and so they were yeah so they would I
think they use the FDIC to harass credit
card companies and banks into not making
it easy for these people to gain access
to ordinary services so I've been very
concerned about the ways in which the
authoritarians attempt to regulate who
can do what who can say what say what
where get banking behave you know but so
that's still going on to this day
yeah there's a difficulty getting
banking like she can't get I think
MailChimp won't work
with her because she's a pornographic
actress in terms of mailing lists yeah
and then there's like chargeback issues
where marginal businesses you know
people will cancel their credit cards
but in fact if you're doing a business
where very few people are cancelling the
credit cards they'll still claim that
they won't work with you because of the
risk of cancellation so there's this
whole thing where we harass and in tax
PayPal payouts no longer supported what
is this Jamie win systems blog yeah
we're all devastated by PayPal's
decision stop payouts to over a hundred
thousand performers who rely on them for
their livelihoods if you have PayPal as
your payout option please select a new
method and update your information in
your model settings tab if you have a
pending payment for October bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla so this is because of
porn canadianmom okay so this but hold
on a second is this prostitution is that
why this payout thing the believe that
once upon a time Sam from the San
Fernando Valley
was the head of prostitution it's a head
of pornographic acting and movie
production because it couldn't be
charged as prosecution now as
prostitution yeah now Ashley makes the
point that she's comfortable being
called a commercial sex worker
so in some sense prostitution adjacent
mm-hmm but not prostitution and in to
your question about how did that go I
was quite nervous about having a
pornographic actress as a guest I did it
in fact right after Sir Roger Penrose so
it was a wonder that one of the better
transition I liked it
thank you for my next trick the I think
it's important that we talk about porn
and I think it's important that if this
is going to have a huge effect like dark
matter
you know you feel its gravitational
effect but nobody can actually see it
because you can't talk about it right I
think that it's absolutely imperative
that we make more connection to Planet
porn and talk about what's going on what
does it say about us and the ways in
which you know they've got great data
though with the way OkCupid has great
data on what's going on in the world of
courtship
horn has great data on what's going on
in the world of tank of kinky
neuroticism yeah and you know for
example she pointed out that incest porn
surges around the holidays when people
are spending time with their families
what Wow an incest porn is a chance as a
cancer that I don't think we're even
talking about that's gotten really
really pronounced
yeah well all taboo porns stepmom porn
you know that kind of stuff stepsister
yeah
there's there's something about I hear
yeah but there's something about those
things that for people it's like there's
so much porn that this is the last taboo
the last taboo is your dad marries is
hot lady and then your dad taboo I want
you to have a good time with your mom
I'm gonna go off golfing lilies and stop
yeah you know you I think with your line
you could do what Iran right you just
did too at me what side the Sean Connery
1 i:r Airlift yeah I could do one yeah
yeah yeah
focus something about a line porn
crossing of lines don't remember damn
sorry what I wanted it I said you don't
even smoke pot hardly I wanted to talk
to you about one of your podcasts I
listened to at least recently you
listened traversal the O'Keefe podcast
ok project Veritas go yeah that's a
that's an interesting one because you
had a really good point in that people
when they hear that this is a project
Veritas thing and for people don't know
who he is James O'Keefe from Project
Veritas they've they've done a lot of
work exposing some biases that are held
by some of the people that work in these
social media groups is social media
corporations like Twitter and Facebook
and things like that yeah but the way
they've done it is all through
hidden-camera type stuff and there's a
narrative that people love to use where
they go oh that guy he uses selective
editing or that guy you can't believe
anything everything he says is wrong but
that is impossible impossible
because you're listening to these people
talking and they're talking about how
they marginalize right-wing viewpoints
they look for people who have like manga
and they're headlined and they put them
in certain categories where make it
makes it very difficult for people to
get there there's stuff that the
algorithm supports you know that they
they know how to marginalize these
perspectives and these points of view
and it's really weird that no one
they've found this strange way of
describing it where even though you see
it on video you hear people say things
that should be outrageous to anyone who
believes in objective reality and yet
people love to say that's just a project
Veritas thing and that guy's full of
[ __ ] and they're always full of [ __ ]
good and then they they cast it aside
well I thank you for bringing that up
the I another look I want to take risk
and that was a huge risk yeah as far as
the thing is that if you touch these
worlds by the way can I try one of these
CBD things yeah well they're not in the
fridge this is the last one can get one
tell Jeff to get some some of the CBD
kill cliffs they're very addictive I'm
gonna warn you right now all right 25
milligrams CBD okay I have a friend who
cannot come to the United States ever
because he attempted to come in with
some CBD which is not such a I shut the
[ __ ] up for me from the UK come on he
can't come in the US ever I believe they
can't appeal that and now the CBD is
legal well his mom is Amanda fielding do
you know who Amanda Fielding yes
do you love Amanda feeling no explain
who Amanda Fielding is Amanda fielding
the countess Amanda fielding is the head
of the Beckley foundation for the
scientific study of psychedelic and
related substances in the UK who I think
believe works with Imperial College
she's an older lady right oh yeah and
she's a she's self trepanned right so
she's right you told me about yeah she's
put two holes in her skull and
her husband Lord Jamie there's the Earl
Jamie maybes Earl - Earl Jamie I'm sorry
I don't know these things okay
he's trip and as well oh great and
they're - they are two of the most
lovely learned wonderful people in the
world what's the benefit of self
trepidation her pollination in general
oh Jesus Christ there's a video of her
doing it yeah I think it's called
something like a hole in my head what is
that it looks like she did it with a
stick
yeah or something she did it herself she
had her own tools why did she do that
first of all when you are British
aristocracy this is what you do no you
don't yes you do you go on vacation no
no no this lady's crazy Jesus Christ
look at that [ __ ] hole she put in her
head so she drilled right through her
skull yeah all right no the reason she
did it and I think it's an interesting
one oh please Joe
come on don't be judgmental the belief
that she had was is that her brain your
brain expands to fill your brain case
and that when it runs into a hard stop
that the blood circulation has changed
and that when the blood circulation
changes you lose that sparkling clarity
that comes from your sort of childhood
and so if you if you remember how clear
the world was when you were a kid her
belief was by relieving the pressure
from the brain case that you actually
get a kind of permanent upgrade in your
cognition and the level at which you're
experiencing all of reality is that true
I don't know I'm not self Japan I have
not well till the old man did she say
that this was like an effective method I
think both she and Jamie say that it's
been very positive
don't [ __ ] out of here with that this is
a different flavour we got a great
flavor
25 milligrams that's crazy though so
this guy is permanently barred cheer sir
yeah permanent be permanently barred
from the United States yeah because of
that DVD yeah on psychoactive right
maybe they just knew his mom was a nut
job that trolls whole she's not a nut
job she was
I made up the one who changed my mind
about psychedelics she changed them yeah
I was a totally I was totally opposed to
the wish I was there to show you the
dumb without having a hole in your head
I I said Randy you've been taking LSD
regularly since the late 60s I said well
how is it that you seemed to be
completely all there really doesn't have
any negative effects and well I'm trying
to race through the story rather than me
yeah perfectly accurate Jesus I said
then what did we get wrong in the
sixties and she said oh dosages I said
what do you mean moronic and so people
were just putting huge amounts of LSD in
things and make terrible experiences and
I thought well okay this is completely
she's crazy because I know it's acid and
so I just had this image that you pour
acid on a brain and it turns it into
emmenthal or cheese with all lots of the
holes and sure enough like we don't even
know what the lethal dosage of LSD is
right and a physiological rather than at
a software level it seems to be
incredibly well tolerated because it is
the only thing that has this effect in
such tiny trace amounts yeah it's the
same as so Simon the ld50 outrageous you
have two pounds of it and so she changed
my mind where I realized that I'd been
thoroughly propagandized and that I had
never examined my beliefs around these
chemicals and then in fact many of the
most powerful appear to be very well
tolerated yes yeah the most powerful
ones in fact but they're also the ones
that most closely resembled human neural
chemistry so which is weird too so I
think that look I'm a fan of eccentrics
and as are you yeah for sure and I don't
think Amanda's crazy oh she's definitely
crazy
so all the holes in her head what gets
weirder than that what else she had a
pet bird called birdy and she built a
mausoleum to her pet bird in the form of
some sort of a conical earth outcropping
that
in order to reach it I think you have to
walk over Doric columns then cross I
mean call like you know these old
columns from Greek temples okay
and so the tops of them form steps
across a moat and it's guarded by attack
swans like you can take nothing at all
psychoactive and then you're visiting
this woman visiting her Birds mausoleum
being attacked by swans walking over
Greek columns to cross a moat yeah but
that's just fun drilling holes in your
head is really really where I draw the
line just seems I mean I don't think
there's any real science to relieving
pressure by drilling a [ __ ] hole in
your head I think you're just relieved
by the fact that you've taken this
really radical step outside the norm and
decided you're gonna be the person who
[ __ ] I'm sorry I'm team Amanda
fielding she met she may have made a
crazy decision in her life but keep
doing it every now and then don't really
new hole just well you know it's like
it's like plastic surgery you get
addicted to it pretty soon there's
nothing for grinder just holes yeah
Swiss cheese had no these these are two
of the most lovely and cerebral people
around and though she on acid when she
drilled the hole I doubt it mmm I mean I
don't think she's sorry I just
I generally I think she's as eccentric
as the day is long but I'm I'm such an
admirer of people who are willing to try
to cross the adaptive valley and do it
and fund their own expedition yeah right
so this is like a giant risk it's just
crazy that so was her son that was
barred from coming in this country the
filmmaker I'm just imagine if you had a
can of this 25 milligram CBD killed
cliff and they're like you [ __ ]
criminal get out of our country but
we're using these things as excuses yeah
like I desperately need to have Douglas
Murray come to the US but people don't
like Douglas because of some of his
opinions but it's been here I don't
think he can come now I don't know
there's some issue was this recent he
was on the podcast when was he last year
years ago - maybe two years ago was he
here in the old spot of the new spot I
feel like it was the new spot it was
here yeah so it's within two years he
can't come to United States I think he
can't come to the United States and I'm
very angry about that and I'll tell you
another one that I'm really angry about
is Alex green the CEO of symmetry labs
if you want to bring up the tree of
ténéré tea and er II from Burning Man
oh boy said Burning Man
what's wrong with Brett have you been no
too many feet 20 what too many feet too
many dirty people okay if you can find a
video there's where all the masks are
they're [ __ ] hoarding them for
Burning Man so like maybe the third one
- 2017 okay okay so the guy that's
beautiful
so this is a tree in Burning Man they've
got all these yeah and okay the guy who
came up with this is rotting right now
in federal prison the guy who came up
with this tree yeah
for what he's a physicist musician a
very good friend of mine somebody I
leave my children with great family
friend wonderful Passover and Shabbat
dinner guests and currently in jail for
weed what weed yeah but like I want you
to think about and there are much better
videos than this where these giant waves
and things go through the people who are
bringing transcendence and grace and
beauty to our lives when they're hounded
because of like what language they've
used things that are like
self-experimentation
advocacy for psychedelics I'm very it's
very important that we have rule
breakers Mavericks people that you might
call crazier lunatics and that we be
very gentle and celebratory what does
this gentleman's name again Alex green
Alex green and Alex Green is was
arrested for distribution yep I think so
how much did he have don't know where
was he arrested I think was New York New
York is still illegal as weird as it may
well be but my
point is I want alligator I want yeah
he's in federal prison I don't know a
couple of few years I don't know with
parole he's in a treatment facility but
you know I just I get a call from my the
keep the person I lead my children with
when I go out of town sitting in federal
prison you know it's like this call
originates from the US Correctional and
this guy said you know he's a he's a
genius CEO of a beautiful mathematical
art company and I just feel so powerless
to figure out how to move people along
was he targeted or did he just [ __ ] up
and try to by a large number of it a
large quantity of it so that he didn't
have to I imagine that he was involved
in some I I don't know the specifics of
his plea and I don't want to say
anything that could screw him up but I
imagine that you know the issue was
something to do with the large cannabis
business okay so he had some sort of
distribution business in New York I'm
not I mean I'm not yeah I'm not opining
that he didn't break the law but I also
think at some level when you go back I
mean you know when you see cannabis
being advertised everywhere and you grew
up in a world in which like only bad
people did that yeah it's pretty
infuriating yeah it is you know and at
some point I was so angry about Alex
that I started talking about coffee and
wine as drugs would you like red drugs
or white drugs today yeah you know hey
should we get go get some drugs down at
Starbucks and people would be like very
weirded out but like tell me those
things aren't drugs they're drugs
they're drugs they're drugs
always have been I only smoked
cigarettes for one weekend in Turkey
years ago man did I not know cigarettes
are a drug I was flying did I don't
smoke but I have smoked before shows
okay with Chappelle he's giving me
cigarettes and Tony Hinchcliffe he's
giving me cigarettes before shows and
I'm smoked a cigarette then we got on
stage and it's like you're you're on a
drug it's a cognitive enhancing drug
by the way five story point and then you
I'm so jittery I can do that I can't
think yeah if you do a bunch of them it
uh there's Society has accepted a bunch
of drugs and a lot of them that will
[ __ ] kill you and then they've made
some drugs that are some of the most
powerful drugs in terms of their force
on creativity to make cannabis is one of
the most amazing drugs ever
the defy terms of creativity do you do
you believe that as true of indica as it
is of sativa yeah indica definitely
gives you some pretty wild thoughts it's
it's really it perturbs normal
consciousness right and in that that
perturbation that if that's words
that'll work that's worth at in that
adjusting of your normal perceptions
that's where these new ideas come come
in that's where these new it's almost
like you get a little a little a chance
to pop your head off the top of the
clouds and look around and go this is
not what I think it is this is some
weird thing you know and I I got really
high the other day and I made a post on
Instagram about Joe exotic and Donald
Trump and then this this thing and I was
like saying like here's what's weird
like the thing that keeps coming to me
when I get high is not it's that decide
the idea that one day things gonna get
back to normal and the idea is that
there would never really wasn't normal
that it was just an attractive illusion
and then it's a comforting and
attractive illusion then I used a photo
of Joe exotic and one of Donald Trump's
most ridiculous tweets we was talking
about the corona virus and how he's a
huge hit and how Aging's
Joe exotic from the new Netflix
documentary series called tiger king
which must be a part of your life get on
board
I don't know any better and then the
other one is look at this that's Joe
exotic it's amazing he's a guy who
smokes meth he's married to two
different guys at the same time they all
live together it's great I don't want to
tell you anymore spoiler alert but Jimmy
go Jamie go to my Instagram so he could
see the Trump tweet that I also included
this post with this image of Joe exotic
because these two things together was
just like I was stunned and Tim Dylan
actually had sent me this this tweet by
Trump and I was it's the second image of
the Joe exotic it's like a double post
so if you click on the image like look
at that President Trump is a ratings hit
since reviving the daily White House
briefings mr. Trump and his coronavirus
updates have attracted an average
audience of 8.5 million on cable news
and reading roughly the viewership of
the season finale of The Bachelor
numbers continue to rise he writes
numbers continue to rise
whatever is leading to this is Donald
Trump the President of the United States
makes a self congratulatory tweet that
his talking about a pandemic virus that
could potentially kill as many as
200,000 American revolutions guilt
revolution Joe look at this
I want a revolt sigh I can't I can't I
get your I get your winder revolt I get
that but me as a high person in the
valley sitting on my back porch while my
kids are asleep looking at this tweet
I'm like well I don't think there is a
normal I don't think normals real
I don't think normals real I think we've
been we've been hoodwinked normals not
real I don't think it is I don't think
it's real I think it's that's one of the
things that I love about nature you know
we were watching a video yesterday of an
owl eating the head off of a hawk
because I was explaining there was a
sort of a hawk war that went on in my
backyard at one point in time these owls
killed these Hawks and I would find
these headless Hawks like owls are mean
[ __ ] oh man they're so big they
look wise and kind but they are they're
badass I know they eat the Hawks heads
that's like the way they do it and I
found this out by googling who the [ __ ]
is hawks heads I finally I would find
these Hawks in the middle of my my yard
with no [ __ ] hat I'm like what is
that it's great owls man they did there
were these badass owls that would by the
weight these Hawks great recommendation
from
you what bunny UFC bunny I had never
seen rabbits fighting oh yeah there's oh
my god there's like I tried to figure
out which are the animals that I want to
see fight the most yeah so giraffes are
way the hell up there oh yeah they fight
wild raft battles are the best
why do UFC is so funny it's funnier it's
like it's like kangaroo fighting for
sure well we didn't know how mean they
were to each other until my daughter's
got two male bunnies and we we left them
in a coop together I'm like oh well this
is not good and they grew up together I
mean these weren't like bunnies that
didn't know each other but they would
fight to the death and they would fight
all the time their ears were all torn
apart we had to separate them yeah so
this is it they fight all the time
they're the rodents man have you seen
penis fencing in flatworms no no I have
not penis focus okay Jamie I learned so
much from you about bizarre animal
sexual behavior all the way back to the
the cuttlefish that pretend to be women
yeah that was a good one that's a really
good one okay there's a lot of men out
there like that in society so this is
penis fencing with flatworms so this is
like in terms of why do people who like
social engineering not like biology
flatworms have two different life cycles
a male and a female life cycle and they
don't know when they encounter each
other and romance calls whether or not
they will be male or female and it's
decided by a violent contest so they've
got I believe to plural of penis die
let's go with Pinay let's see one at any
given moment they have two penises and
they attempt to stab each other and
whoever penetrates the other and
succeeds in what might be termed
traumatic insemination and the loser is
assigned the feminine gender right so
the idea is that it's more costly to
bear the
than it is to pierce the opponent so
female is given to the loser
whoa so they just do battle until
someone [ __ ] the other one right that's
the person becomes a check now for that
thing now there's a worse species what
bed bugs bed bugs have no vaginal
opening and so to make one the only way
that a female can bear young is if a
male attacks her thorax and breaks it
open in an act which is definitely
called traumatic insemination so you
know you have a situation in which
violent rape is the only method by which
females can leave young so what they do
to you when you stay in a hotel is just
child's play compared to what they do my
point is if you want to talk about
eradicating bedbugs with DDT I'm all for
it they are the the feminists worst
nightmare species and I you know you and
I talked about the natural world look
like well that they blow up like
balloons I think so if you see one
that's flat it hasn't really gorged so
they're like ticks ish
anyway the we had them under control I
believe due to DDT and but on my list of
10 nightmare species bedbugs and
flatworms for the twin traumatic
inseminations would be way up at the top
so it's like a needle so they literally
puncture through the thorax within oh
there we go oh Christ
yeah now these are if there is a good
lord boy this does he or she have a lot
to answer for
yeah what did you do you [ __ ] why did
you make bedbugs and why'd you make it
like that imagine what kind of natural
selection takes place where the only way
that you can reproduce is through
violent rape
well it's interesting there's a
different system which i think is
fascinating which is there's a conserved
quantity
in dung beetles where they have weaponry
on their heads in the form of antlers
for fighting the males and it turns out
that there's an inverse relationship so
there's some resource that's allocated
between the copulatory equipment and the
weaponry that the that the bed that the
dung beetle has if they have a lot of
weapons out there goes the Sean Connery
that's good barrel thing yeah I love it
excellent I've tried it for years thank
you can't do it I don't know if it's
just a failure
okay the larger the weaponry the smaller
the copulatory effort oh so it's like a
monster truck thing yeah if you don't
have it going God you got to go get
yourself a monster truck that tiny
little gun admitted anyway so what
happens is is that the size of the
copulatory apparatus may be the engine
of speciation that when a male's
equipment no longer fits the female that
may be the cue that some dung beetles
will speciate because they can't
reproduce effectively and we don't know
why the conserved quantity would be
spread between fighting equipment which
is used only to displace rivals and the
size of the package when I'm going on a
tour of the Vatican I had a really great
guide it was really cool he took my
family through this thing and he was he
was a professor and he was really happy
that I was so curious about things so
and so whoever wandering around billions
of dollars of stolen art and one of the
things I kept saying ago why are their
penis is so small like what's going on
with that and he was like that's a
really important question and he's like
back then the thought was that bigger
penises were brutish and that they were
that these you know you got to realize
these are people that were fending off
barbarians and the idea was that their
gods would be beautifully proportion
but they would have these small sort of
less dangerous penises it's very nice
yeah yeah they would they would make
them like that on purpose they were all
they all had little dicks all of them
and I'm like these guys like if you
looked at these guys like just the way
they were built
yeah the reality is most of them would
have hogs hmm right these are heavily
muscled Jannik thick men with a lot of
testosterone they would have big dicks
most likely right that's the reason why
women find that build attractive
probably other than the fact that it's
gonna be the person who'd be more
successful protecting you from said
barbarians well I think that is it true
that the castrati of Italy were sought
after as lovers they could still perform
really yeah but then you didn't need to
worry about pregnancy how could they
could get erect yeah when they were
castrate that doesn't mean any sense
they're wrong
yeah I don't think that's correct I
think they're eunuchs I think that's why
they would do that to men I mean men who
would work in castles and they would
have eunuchs that would work with the
Queen I guess they could leave well I
don't know what what the definite what
operation was performed on the castrati
they would eat Ostrom okay but I
believed that there was a way in which
they were sought after as lovers maybe
that's probably what it is what just
kind of Lingus yeah I actually think
that they were able to say I'm not sure
what operation was done but I believe
that they were able to sexually perform
in a conventional way Jamie and if you
could find the plural for penis that's
got a keen eye yeah yeah
penises just sounds so [ __ ] crude
[Laughter]
well dicks is real that's the right way
to say it
[ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] yeah you don't say
[ __ ] I might start do you know the the
Michael Jackson story I know some man
this is one of the Michael Jackson
stories that I was promoting before it
actually was confirmed by his doctor the
doctor that wound up killing him then
went to jail I was like the way that guy
sings
I was aware of castrati I'm like he
sounds like one of them yeah he sounds
like is his permanent female voice well
the doctor that went to jail for
sedating him and when he wound up dying
dr. Jackson right right whatever the
guys name was that guy confirmed that
Michael Jackson was chemically castrated
by his father to preserve his voice and
they did it to him at a young age Wow
because when he makes sense well that in
retrospect it's like the end of the
usual suspects like okay 100% makes
sense if you look at the rest of his
family look at Tito or Jermaine they
look like men right they're these thick
men like a normal man yeah and then you
look at him he's incredibly slender like
he has no muscle at all and he moves
like he's got this you know there's this
dance style that is like quasi feminine
almost right it's like he's singing like
a woman like it's like why why tell him
that it's human nature like what what is
that that's not a male voice right and
hits incredible notes well the idea was
that his father wanted to preserve what
got them to the dance I mean this is a
performing entertaining family he was
the number one he wasn't he was the
genius man just yeah well you know what
else do you know that okay here's what
we're doing the rivalry between the
Nicholas brothers and I think the Barry
brothers do you know have you ever heard
of the story who's the Barry brothers
they were two dancing groups and the
Nicholas brothers were just in terms of
riffing off this Michael Jackson brought
back the Nicholas brothers the Nicholas
brothers if you can find this were maybe
two of the greatest dancers ever what
yours is they came out of probably like
the 1930s and 40s and like Fred Astaire
and Nureyev and all these people just
thought these are the guys oh yeah oh I
am so these I think that maybe Cab
Calloway even yeah I believe that is
and just in terms of like the femininity
the elegant nature of these guys and
both of them geniuses and they could do
anything yeah they're incredible look
how great they dance my god oh my god
the way he's moving his hips back and
forth and his legs go sideways like what
incredible control I just say how much I
love being an American I love all the
stuff that comes out of this country and
I we need to get back to being ourselves
what are you talking about we're being
ourselves right now no or not we're not
what are we doing well right now we're
we're looking now if you check out
look at this castrati we're also
supposed to be great lovers they could
last long says toe masini to say that
name montesque we how do you say that -
montes Montez squee men's squad they
would have inspired a taste for Gomorrah
in people whose taste is the least
depraved what and when Casanova fell in
love with a castrato who conveniently
turned out to be a woman in drag he
asked her to dress as a castrato in bed
okay I'm done check please for those
women for those women who choose as
dried and put it - in quotes in soft
UNIX place their bliss and shun the
scrubbing of a bearded kiss yeah they
wanted someone who eats a lot of [ __ ]
affairs were idolized and safe but
bed-hopping could be risky for the
castrati one was assassinated by his
lovers furious family and another who
wrote to the Pope requesting permission
to marry on the basis of that his
castration had been ineffective received
the reply let him be castrated better
the Pope said no you can't get married
we're gonna cut your nuts off better
gonna do a better job all mouth and no
trousers castrati had more fun than you
could thank hello Guardian great [ __ ]
Samantha Ellis meets a singer who wishes
he'd had the chop oh yeah
there's get but won't see this might
just be a story you know what I mean the
guy says I regret not having been cast
Ruthie go get cast we'll hear something
crazy but that's that's one of those
things where that's just that might be a
story like a good way to write something
maybe no and click baby and it's been
around for a long time
here's the we may not know the last
castrato was recorded see if there's
actually a requirement played about a
dozen times yeah yeah it's pretty gross
it's not good he wasn't a talented one
well that's not what's gross was gross
as the thought that this was a child
that was taken and castrated and then
for me to live this life look it's it's
absolutely ridiculous but getting back
to Michael Jackson I think there is is
that right yeah Alessandro Mora chechi
more set more ski more SG more SG
Alessandro more SG the last castrato
Christ the complete Vatican recordings
what did they do that man's mouth well
they had him there so Barry brothers is
the Barry brothers were a rival team to
the Nicholas brothers and there did we
see with those guys the Barry brothers
Nichols Nichols why there's nobody
remembers the Barry brothers if anybody
remembers anything they remember the
Nicholas brothers okay but the issue is
that the Barry brothers were there's the
Barry brothers oh that this you'll see
that they are much more athletic in a
certain sense and much less refined so
doing a lot of cane twirling yeah but if
you go to the end of this one I believe
it's pretty awesome look I mean there's
a scene where they you see those stairs
mm-hmm
they're about to do some things Christ
look at that yeah Oh spinning and then
drop it into the splits
all right well keep keep keep on this
running up the stairs and then oh my god
oh my god they jumped off the top of the
stairs which we're talking about a good
solid ten feet and they landed it into a
split all right now that that's a nut
Smasher okay
yes guys look at that look at that BAM
that is insane right three of them and
then they did backflips right three of
them oh my god that's a very impressive
feat that's like that's like parkour but
you never heard of these guys with a
ball slam no but I mean it's like the
1920s right well that's gonna be later
than the twice was it yeah God yeah my
thirties forties amazing the way they
jumped off the top and language I've
never seen the hellzapoppin sequence no
put in hellzapoppin this is this just a
whole ease up bopping Elza bopping and
then dance hell's a pop and dance hell's
about yeah
okay now go into the middle of it
because there's a bunch of setup here
that no farther okay
Jesus Christ oh my god so this is a guy
and a girl and so he throws her over his
back oh my god I mean if people can do
anything
whoa but the amount of practice and how
you would practice something like this
the real thing that would be insane to
practice is that jump off the top into
the split was man its athleticism
artistry and I means and you know this
is also it's incredible oh my god it's
pro wrestling my god I mean what is them
well we should we listen to the music
but would get no no don't don't do that
but it just I want people to be aware of
the level of artistry and skill that
came out of places like Hart Harlem it's
just all of this is pure American
engineer and this is 41 and you know
these are hard shoes with like slippery
soles that oh my god was it what's
amazing is that these guys can get any
traction to do any of it and the girl
just did that to him
holy [ __ ] is the best of the best this
is odd right my god amazing know what I
love about this program Joe is is I get
to take stuff like this and blow it out
to people at like millions at a time
well
what I love about having you on I would
love to learn something about this this
isn't me how the [ __ ] I'm in the balls
and send him flying oh my god people on
YouTube watching you have to Google oh
okay yeah please do this is insane and
this is 1941 my god right and if you
want to think about like partnerships
between men and women and the way in
powers this is passed back and forth
between people of equal abilities just
astounding well yeah I mean there's no
one person who is the the head of this
like he's throwing her oh my god that's
incredible that they can do that Wow
that's one of the more amazing things
about computer technology like the the
footage that they did with World War one
where they took some of that footage and
colorized it and smoothed it out and you
know use computers to sort of fill in
the the choppiness of it and it's almost
like have you seen my friend Lee you
should have Alecia Lee on the show
rosebud ai is going to make models a
thing of the past she can generate like
tens of thousands of people who've never
existed and you can't tell the
difference and like you know how that
your optometrist says is it better like
this or like this fantastic yeah she
could create for you you're absolutely
perfect
you know visual mate and there's no way
of having this person or asking them out
because they don't exist
and there's no way of telling whether
they're real or fake
so it's increasingly I just can't what
is her name
Alicia Lee Alicia yeah she's a PhD in
like math or statistics from Berkeley
and again one of these people who can do
absolutely anything art dance
programming high level theory and so her
company is rosebud a I know she she's
also an actress Wonder Woman Jesus one
of them huh yep when I'm confusing
people one of them confusing people but
it's unclear whether models will still
have a job
Wow good go to work skinny [ __ ] become
something more interesting than just a
hanger how about that so what what what
are the episodes of my of my puck cuz I
launched it off of this one yes I listen
Werner Herzog yeah I thought that was
interesting although he's a little bit
self congratulatory which is a little
shocking but he is the most interesting
man you know it's very interesting guy
he's also been in some really terrible
movies like he was in that Jack Reacher
movie with Tom Cruise the best part
about that movie is that he drives a
Chevelle 1970 Chevelle don't know that
you don't know about 70 Chevelle did you
listen to that bread up Bret episode
Bret Weinstein Oh your brother no I did
not listen to that one okay I've also
listened to five or six if you listen to
him to episode 19 which is the bread
episode I think that's been the most
important one and except for the one
released today that sounds like your
gear me up for the one released today
well I just start with the I would start
with the Bret one and what's so
important about the Bret one the Bret
one is a story about his prediction that
all the laboratory mice that we use from
the major supplier which is the Jackson
Laboratory in Bar Harbor Maine may have
been compromised by their breeding
protocols which allowed the telomeres to
radically elongate and that we thought
that these mice were representative of
all mice and that they had radically
elongated telomeres at the end of their
chromosomes which appear to mediate the
level of mitosis that can happen during
histological repair so if you imagine
that your cells can divide a certain
number of times if if there isn't a
counter that stops the number of
divisions everything can become tumors
and since you have like 30 trillion or
100 trillion cells in your body it means
every cell almost can kill you so it
appears that the reason we may die from
senescence that is aging is
that that's our anti-cancer mechanism so
if you eliminate like infectious disease
like viruses and insult from you know
being hit by a car the two things that
you have in the end is either you die
from immortality which is cancer which
wear cells can divide an infinite number
of times or you die from the recursion
limit which is how many times the cell
can divide called in biology the
hayflick limit and Brett predicted from
first principles that what we thought
about mice which is that they have
radically elongated telomeres was only
true for laboratory animals because all
the laboratory animals in which we test
things like drugs have been broken
they've been broken because of selective
breeding yep because the breeding
rotations privileged much younger mice
and removed all sort of threats from the
environment and so because telomeres are
not protein coding there are sequences
of nucleotides that repeat as a counter
rather than coding for a translation in
the ribosome in into amino acid
sequences what you have is is that the
body can mutate if you will and to use
the jackson laboratories concept of this
very rapidly because it's not building
something structural it's just a
question of do we have 17 on the end or
170 on the end because that it's acting
nucleic acid has multiple ways in which
it can participate in regulating the
body's responses so in fact the breeding
protocols constituted a novel system of
selective pressures that destroy the
efficacy of all of our laboratory
animals potentially holy [ __ ] so and so
he predicted from first principles he
said I bet if you test wild-type mice
rather than laboratory mice you'll find
that their telomeres are not long as you
believe and this was actually carried
out by Carol Greider who did not
acknowledge the prediction she didn't
acknowledge the prediction you should
listen to the show why did she not
acknowledge some sugars into the show
it's it's okay it's no because it's it's
it's this is serious kids and it's a
Nobel laureate on the other side of this
so we're
taking some risk over that over there at
the portal that's really interesting so
the consequences of this could be grave
it could be that so much of the studies
that are predicated on these mice tests
are they're useless well I've called up
the Jackson laboratory and asked them
Wendy have you had any changes in your
breeding protocol are you they said we
don't even count the number of telomeres
at the telomere length I say do you have
a history of when you've changed the
breeding protocols are you aware of
these articles and she said like what I
said you know these articles of Carol
Greider and they said how do you spell
glider like the plane I said Grider like
the Nobel laureate and how do you spell
that
GRE ID er and so and then they said to
me well we don't remember if we've
changed the protocols I said you're
producing laboratory animals I would
imagine you would have a documented
history of every change in the time
series of how these animals were
prepared well I don't know if there's
anyone around from that time are you
kidding were you absent the day they
taught science who are you you know this
like a single point of failure if true I
can't even
we've been at for 20 years we've been
trying to get an answer as 20 years that
no one will break the story I mean this
episode which is almost impossible to
listen to because at the beginning of
the episode I'm absolutely insufferable
to Bret because he won't tell the story
he's afraid to tell his own life story
why won't he tell the story because in
academics the idea of some punk kid
alleging that they predicted in a
telephone call to a Nobel laureate that
if they would test wild-type mice the
telomeres would be radically along
radically shorter than the elongated
telomeres of the laboratory test and
then the person refuses to acknowledge
that such a prediction was made even
though we have emails from the lab that
so she refuses to acknowledge it or she
doesn't I cannot find a single I've been
over the literature there is no mention
anywhere of and I and I live this with
bread in real time so I I know the
events were happening we have
communications with that lab since there
is I cannot find any acknowledgement
from the Johns Hopkins University
laboratory that this interaction ever
took place and that because he called
and wrote and did not write an email he
did not have a paper trail of that
prediction
now there's consequential consequential
emails that show the interaction between
the labs but how many times have you
ever heard anyone predict a molecular
result from first principles in
evolutionary theory this is what Brett
was supposed to be famous for and then
you know he he became like this obscure
professor at some ridiculous College and
then this thing happened to him but
that's not his origin story his origin
story is that he is the badass of
biology who was able to make this
prediction from first principles and may
have advanced the theory of why we have
to die balance between deaths from
immortality that is tumors and deaths
from recursion limits that is telomere
mediated hate flicks hayflick limit so
what if anything has been done since
this information has gotten out the
world went crazy for the episode and
there was silence everywhere inside of
what I've called the gated institutional
narrative because to acknowledge it yeah
they really have to throw out how much
research we don't know I don't know but
it puts the question out how much
research is compromised by the rebbe
laboratory breeding protocols and
breeding rotations from a single point
of failure at the Jackson Laboratories
in Bar Harbor Maine Wow
episode 19 you know and you will hear
me in a way where you will just say Eric
is the biggest dick I've ever heard in
my life but it's all to push this Brett
to actually talk you should have him
back on the show to talk about its it
skill I would love to yeah so he just
wants to he kind of wants to soft dance
it is that what it is soft step is just
wrong I mean here's the problem there's
a point after which I'm not mr. nice guy
and I'm just like adamant mm-hmm Brett
is simply wrong it's a it's a result and
a story that needs to be told if there
is another side to the story we need to
hear the other side of the story and my
goal is to have Carol Greider say you
know what this interaction did happen
and I probably could have handled this
better because she has work that she's
done which is beyond question some of
the most important work that has nothing
to do with anything Brett has done but
it does not give that laboratory the
scientific right to deny the existence
of this interaction the importance of
the interaction and because there are
potential downstream consequences in
pharmaceuticals we need to have an
answer and every answer is interesting
like if the laboratory mice having
radical added radically elongated
telomeres is not a problem in some way
that's fascinating how could you have an
animal that has this huge adaptation to
the laboratory not affect things that
would be interesting if it does affect
things that's fascinating especially if
you if you're running tests on it that
have anything to do with telomeres right
well no but if it doesn't have to do
like for example let's say you have a
really toxic substance right and it
causes a lot of cell death that requires
histological repair well if you have
huge long telomeres you're gonna have an
ability to metabolize that toxicity very
much better right right you'll be able
to take the insult that comes from this
and so these mice are probably
preternatural II disposed towards
radical histological repair that's why
they remain youthful and young and if
you test something that might be you
know if you're doing toxicology studies
it could be that the telomeres even
though you're not testing the telomeres
what you're actually doing is picking up
that these broken mice are like the
world champs of repair but they suck at
cancer
they all die of cancer all of them yeah
almost if you essentially all the mice
that was radically elongated telomeres
let go long enough all died of cancer
because they're they're tricked out for
one special thing which is weird
yeah we are the best at repair Wow right
so think about it is the theory of death
and then clear away all of the noise
there are two ways that that nature
can't figure out an escape from either
you dive in mortality which is that you
think all your cells want to want to
live forever you know and that's a huge
death a huge danger or we call it a
resource lake leak in computers or they
die because the only thing nature can
figure out to do is to say you only get
a finite number of cell divisions up
front now that there's some adjustments
to the theory but if you only get it
like if you if you look at the moles on
my face which your people love to
comment on comment section they probably
started as a runaway replica replicative
process that arrested at the border of
the mole in order to keep that from
killing me all right so we have cells
that go rogue all the time but then what
happens is is that there's some means of
making sure that it the process doesn't
take down the entire organism but think
about 30 trillion assassins as the cells
in your body all of which might kill you
at any moment it's like terrifying and
today's podcast today's podcast so first
of all you can reach it now I finally
got a website which is Eric Weinstein
org and I told you that we have to leave
this planet and that sorry it's just
hard dot the left but you're serious I'm
have to leave this planet we have to
leave this planet why why do I have to
well this one look because we can't all
be cuz plan has the best beaches this
planet says China Russia Iran in the
United States under ridiculous
leadership
there's lots of reasons why we have to
leave this planet we're not good
stewards we're not wise enough to stay
on this planet we're too powerful we
went through this and by the way you
pointed out this quote which is we are
now gods but for the wisdom and that
became a meme so that was very
interesting the I I gave these lectures
I think in 2013 it's almost the best
quotes ever isn't it don't know and
Oxford who originated that quote there
was me that was you then when did you
say it on your program what day I took
which one remember which one you
probably do in clip I'm trying to think
about what it just came off my tongue
and you it's one of those ones where
I'll Drive down the street and it'll pop
in my head like the nicest person there
no no no it's it's a it's a fantastic
quote but it's so right it's like every
now and then someone can get the whole
thing in a sentence we now God's but for
the wisdom so that's why we have to get
off this planet diversify because
they're too many people have godlike
powers like Donald Trump commands a
tremendous amount of godlike power
thanks to our physics community well his
ratings see how are they are so focused
sorry okay so no too much godlike power
right so the best hope that I can come
up with and it's a slim one is is that
if we could figure out what goes beyond
Einstein's theory the Einstein Ian speed
limit might be bendable or breakable
because we would be in a framework that
was larger than Einstein's people often
interpret this is what they call FTL or
faster than light travel but that's not
what I mean necessarily what I mean is
is that the underlying source code gives
us opportunities that we don't normally
have so seven years ago I try to release
I tried giving these lectures at Oxford
which is probably the university that is
spiritually closest to what I care about
because they care about geometry and
physics and the interrelationship
they've kept the face with a faith with
that tradition through people like Roger
Penrose and Michael the tea
and I released this theory of geometric
unity or rather I released the video of
the lecture that introduces this theory
so this was the first time since 1983 84
that I talked in public when I started
this program when I was eighteen
nineteen something like that and I just
released the video today on our YouTube
channel and it's the video of you giving
this discussion yeah so it's introduced
by professor Marcus - so toi who has
Richard Dawkins old job as the Simoni
professor for the public understanding
of science and he just he met me in a
bar and he got me - a little drunk I
said okay what are you really working on
and I told him and the first it sounded
crazy and then he started thinking about
it and he asked me more questions and he
brought me over to Oxford he got me an
appointment had me talked to their
experts and then he decided that he
wanted me to give these what he called
special Simoni lectures and they are an
attempt to go beyond Einstein to look
for a unified theory of physics between
the two major branches that have
resisted unification and that's usually
in the modern era confused with the idea
of quantizing gravity but the quantity
the quantum gravity imperative is a it's
a political program that comes out of
what would have been the quantum field
theory community before it became the
string theory community the idea is we
have to take n stein and make him submit
to the will of Bohr and I don't think
it's exactly like that there I think
they got it wildly wrong and they
synchronized themselves and sort of took
the field off the cliff and they weren't
able to ship a product they couldn't
deliver on any of this promise and so
when I saw that they were about to go
off a cliff
I switched fields as an undergraduate
into mathematics and used mathematics as
a stalking horse to study the same sort
of underlying structures but not to get
swept up in the politics of physics
and I had this theory which I can now
talk about for the first time in like 37
years or whatever it is and like today's
the first day that I'm sort of free
because I've kept this to myself so if
you want to ask any question about
geometric unity but why why did you keep
this to yourself cuz I don't trust these
people you don't trust these people in
the like I know there was some people
that have written some Oracle it wasn't
a Shawn doesn't matter if it's not them
it's it's an entire system that believes
in peer-review it believes in its forced
citations you have to be at a university
you have to get an endorsement to use
the preprint server it's too few
resources and too many sharp elbows do
you think that there's there's a logic
to that method no I think to preserve it
from charlatans and yeah you have to do
jackpot Center yeah they just want to
publish stories yep so this way you have
to be Spencer it makes sense right
yes but it whatever I'm doing whatever
mistakes I'm making so much so what I'm
wrong about it about this theory that's
just fine
I'll find out that I'm wrong give me the
layman's version of the theory all right
first time never yeah do you know that
let's start off with Usher's drawing
hands mm-hmm
so do you Jamie do you have a picture
for that the key problem that we have in
a fundamental theory that people don't
think about is not why is there
something rather than nothing I don't
think we can answer that it's why is
there so much that is that is rich out
of almost nothing and so this issue
shows that if you had a piece of paper
could you will into being the hands
holding pens using ink to draw each
other right that problem is akin to the
problem that we face in a fundamental
theory if you had the canvas how would
the canvas bring all of the richness
that you see around you into being and
what I did was I said okay we have to go
below Einstein so we have four degrees
of freedom but they're not yet space and
time
it's proto space-time but before and
then I said okay that those four degrees
of freedom are like the stands in a
stadium and the stands somehow need to
build the pitch and the pitch is a 14
dimensional space so if let's imagine
that you had okay we have got four
objects here right so the four degrees
of freedom correspond to the four
objects then we need a ruler to measure
how much of each of these four objects
we have so that would be four additional
variables and then you have angles
because length and angle is what
Einstein gave us in space-time so the
angles between any two objects are the
same as the reverse of the angle so then
you can count it up and there are six
angles to be had so there's four degrees
of freedom plus four rulers
plus six protractors which is 14 so
there's a 14 dimensional auxiliary space
and in my estimation you and I are in
some ways potentially having this
conversation in a 14 dimensional world
that we perceive back in the stands
rather than on the pitch as a
four-dimensional conversation that is
we're in a three-dimensional room going
forward in time so I've called this the
observers and the observers is two
spaces rather than Einsteins one space
stop you right there sure why 14
dimensions because I'm saying that the
fields that is the stuff is dancing not
mostly on the four dimensions that we
think we perceive but it's also dancing
on the rulers and the protractors so in
other words if I have XY and Z I need
rulers in the X direction in the Y
direction and the Z to measure things
and I need a watch which would be like a
ruler in the time direct so those four
rulers are in fact in play as well and
they're the protractors because like
space time is four degrees of freedom
plus rulers and protractors I'm saying
work over the space of all rulers and
all protractors as part of where these
particles and fields can dance
so the rulers and the protractors are
part of the system not just a choice of
particular rulers and particular
protractors so by choosing particular
rulers in particular protractors
Einstein is grabbing a tiny filament of
the space of all possible rulers and
protractors so an in effect space-time
is recovered as the act of the observers
contemplating itself it's a little bit
poetic but I mean that the choice of a
spacetime metric inside of the space of
all metrics is a section of a 14
dimensional bundle over a four
dimensional space now that's the first
sort of mind-bending weird thing is is
that this is not happening in one place
it's happening in two places in X and in
Y the stands and the pitch there are
things that are happening in the stands
and there's things that are happening in
the pitch so you know when a guy is like
trying to make a free throw and
everybody's waving their giant noodles
trying to get him to miss there's an
interaction between what's happening in
the stands and what's happening on the
floor and then the observer is the
bundling of two spaces and saying hey
you you're confused as to what's going
on here some fields are happening in the
stands some fields are happening on the
floor and there everything feels as if
it's happening in the stands because
that's where you're sitting in some
weird way then you've got this really
crazy stuff which I think one aspect of
it is everybody in theoretical physics
is looking to figure out whether there
are three or more generations that is
copies of matter everything in this room
is generational one it's all made up of
up quarks down quarks and electrons so
that up quarks and down quarks give you
protons and neutrons and electrons give
you a sort of interesting personality of
the various chemical elements they're
also neutrinos but they're streaming
through us I'm not going to count them
and that's all generation one of matter
so everything in that think of that is
like plastic Lego then there's another
Lego set made out of wood and then
there's another Lego set made out of
like lead you know and we don't see
those other two LEGO sets and except if
we're doing very energetic experiments
so there were three copies of matter
and everybody was trying to figure out
three or more and I thought maybe it's 2
or fewer and so one of the aspects of
this theory is is that the third
generation of matter is an impostor it
looks like this generation of matter in
terms of its particle personalities but
if you were actually to heat up the
system it would unify with a bunch of
particles nobody's ever seen before and
so there are predictions for what those
new particle properties would be there's
also a fourth pseudo generation of what
would be called spin three-halves matter
which is not prohibited but has never
been seen as a fundamental so it makes
predictions for the particle properties
of new spin 1/2 and new spin
three-halves particles it attempts to
say that there are sectors of matter
that I think decoupled that the universe
is not in fact left-right asymmetric
which would be called chirality and if
you think about the weak force so if you
have a neutral neutral on a table it'll
decay and I think something like 17
minutes on average half-life when it
decays there's an asymmetry in that
decay called beta decay and that was
found by a woman bring up madame woo
from columbia and the cobalt-60
experiment so in the 50's this this gal
madam woo who should have want to know
about prized discovered that when
cobalt-60
decays through beta decay the electrons
come spin out one side and not the other
meaning that the universe is like
Marilyn Monroe or Cindy Crawford having
a birthmark that lets you tell the left
from the right so this is like the
ultimate experimental badass who never
got recognized fully she did an
experiment based on work of Yang and Lee
that for the first time showed that the
universe had a preference of one of its
left over it's right if you will I don't
believe that preference is fundamental I
believe that there's an another copy of
matter that so the analogy I give is
that if you think if you look at your
three fingers in the center of your hand
your middle finger which is my favorite
is obviously symmetrical about itself
your digit ratio 2 and 4 is pretty close
but is determined by the amount of test
Tyrone you're exposed to in utero and
then your thumb and your pinky are
wildly off but you could try to make it
symmetric and say well yeah you know a
pinky is like a lame thumb which it
isn't if you're just looking at your
hand you're trying to figure why is my
hand asymmetrical but you don't realize
that you've got another hand and it's
thumb to thumb not thumb to pinky that
is the symmetry so when you you know
place your fingertips together you see
that if you didn't know if you were like
Oliver sexed out and you could only see
part of your body you would think about
oh the world is asymmetric while my
belief is that it in weak gravitational
situations this other matter decouples
so you only see one hand or the other
and we're all in one handedness so what
I'm starting to do is is that I'm
terrified of talking about this stuff I
don't have the right credentials not a
physicist I've been out of this game for
forever so I often say the wrong things
and break rules and who knows what and I
haven't really talked about it this is
like really a very loans I mean I've
been completely alone on this project
don't want my life what do you think the
end result of this project potentially
could be because you're saying we could
get off his planet what he would like
what are you talking about in terms of
the actual implementation of this this
theory of yours so Jamie if you could
bring up my answer to the final edge
question which is what is the last
question Jon Brockman asked when the
final year that he conducted the annual
edge question and that is the annual
edge question yes he would ask like 200
people many of them physicists or
biologists or mathematicians you'd ask a
question and they'd write an essay and
then every year he'd publish it as a
book when so I did that for 10 years
finally got tired of it and he said ok
this is my final year we've exhausted
this what is the last question so this
is the question that I asked so does
something unprecedented happen when we
finally learn our own source code now
nobody picked up on this but that's what
my concern is which is what happens when
the universe finally contemplates itself
when we're the first
like we're always worried about the AI
becoming self-aware alla Skynet mm-hmm
okay
we are the AI and we're about to become
self-aware if we can figure out what our
own source code is so we are Skynet so
you're talking about the source code of
reality itself yep and that our
perception our limited perceptions of
reality are giving us a distorted view
of what the landscape actually is we're
I'm trying to make sure I was somewhat
holding this back because I'm afraid of
what it unlocks and now that I know that
we're willing to elect Donald Trump not
store masks play footsie with China be
Putin's [ __ ] all of this stuff uh
to hell with this we're gonna miss
manage this planet into Armageddon if we
don't get some grown-ups into the room
and so I don't know that I'm a grown-up
but I'm willing to vie for leadership by
putting something up having it
investigated and seeing where it goes
what is your number-one fear about this
this source code being I don't know less
of a better term mastered well the last
time we gained some serious insight into
the way nuclei worked that with a little
bit of geometry from Stanislaw ulam
and Edward Teller gave us the the
namesake of the bikini that was a
terrifying moment we change everything
changed in 19 I think that was 54 the
namesake of the bikini a bikini atoll
was an island in the Pacific where we
blew up a hydrogen device is that that
inside those insane images where you
could see the water going a mile high
into the sky gorgeous yeah is that what
that is yeah but they did that a lot
right well they did it for a period of
time now and so it went to your question
what if what so it's still expensive to
create fusion devices so we don't know
of any individuals who own the ability
to create fusion devices if you recall
at some point somebody made a
functioning nuclear reactor at
discarded smoke detectors and we're got
like 500 smoke detectors took out the
radioactive element created a reactor
really think so
so kid right yeah probably a kid who
couldn't get into Harvard so we have a
situation in which we don't know when
ordinary humans will gain limitless
destructive power you know try to
imagine the Columbine kids weaponizing
viruses or something like that so one of
the great dangers is that great power I
can't tell what the power would be if
the theory is correct it might give us
the ability to escape it might but you
say escape though yeah why do we have to
escape this is what what I'm I'm always
so confused about like cuz even when
Elon talks about going to Mars yeah
quick marsh sucks Mars sucks can't you
fix here would that be the best approach
well you wouldn't agree on that yeah
what we don't agree on I think is is
that I'm convinced that we don't have
the ability to steward this place
why don't you think we're better now
than we were a thousand years ago no no
no so Genghis Khan was doing a better
job Genghis Khan was doing a better job
because he didn't have limitless power
just try to imagine it try to imagine a
full-on nuclear interchange and then
we're having this conversation
afterwards so you you're concerned that
nuclear war is not just possible but
inevitable it's certainly inevitable
given a long enough time series because
all these weapons simply will become
cheaper there's no countermeasure that
we it's too easy to destroy things
relative to building right do you think
that when we're looking at the failure
of leadership on the scale that we're
seeing play out because of this pandemic
that this is indicative of how would go
no matter what went wrong
yes yeah like if this was an issue of
forest fires if it was a an issue of
climate destruction if this was an issue
volcanoes hurricanes nuclear war same
thing same thing like you
no here's a weird one the suit look at
look at the history
Jamie of the SU vyas eruptions by year
since the 1800s a bit my guess is that
Wikipedia would probably have a list and
the last one was in 1944-45 during World
War Two grounded a bunch of planes and
then Vesuvius stops erupting like what
went while they overdue for Vesuvius
eruption and then when IQ fella cool
erupted in Iceland like we we hadn't
realized that the era of jet travel in
the developed world had happened during
an incredibly quiet period of volcanic
activity
so did we build any kind of volcanic
sensitivity into these planes
no we just grounded the fleet right and
there's a there's a volcano not so far
from I can fella cool called Kepler some
makes makes IQ fella cool look like a
like child's play yeah so you have to
look at the big nap as the greatest
danger to all of us and at this point
about about being Jewish is that you
know to be really Jewish Chet ben
shapiro makes a point which is not very
popular which is a lot of people call
themselves Jews aren't actually Jews
that really Jews on the way out people
who can't figure out why they're keeping
these traditions up they sort of like to
go three days a year mumble a few words
there's something intrinsically Jewish
about wanting gold bars someplace where
you can grab them you know knowing where
the exits are on a building like you
have to be prepared because the problem
of anti-semitism to leave at a moment's
notice and Jews have always lived like
this and many of us have forgotten
because we've we've gotten soft in a in
a world with you know knock wood
anti-semitism well prevalent has been
under control in the US for a long time
and I think we've weirdly become
denatured
because we haven't been living with open
anti-semitism you see a crop up in the
comment section of every video but it's
incredibly important to stay in a state
of readiness and I've tried to keep that
story about Passover and the Exodus into
Israel from what Jews call Mitzrayim
which means the narrow places or Egypt
so my contention is the Jews had a great
run in Egypt and we are all the Jews and
earth is Mitzrayim
and it's time to go where we're going we
don't know that we can go anywhere this
is a recapitulation of our previous
conversation right we have to know
whether exoplanets are viable whether we
can spread out and whether or not
they're in the middle of a big sleep
well they may be right but if we're
running a million different experiments
it's different than if we're running one
correlated experiment with Donald Trump
at the helm of the most dangerous
machine ever created in the world like
that was not my plan so the formulation
of this theory what you're trying to do
is revolutionize space travel no what
you're trying to do is make it possible
for us and we found out we've been
stalled out for almost 50 years in
theoretical physics
so install that also so the simplest way
of saying it is no one younger than
Frank will check who was born in 1951
has gone to Stockholm for a discovery in
theoretical fundamental physics made
since like 1973 physics effectively the
the prestige part of physics came to an
end in the early 70s when everything
changed across the board we had a broad
economic change in our world Jamie do
you want to bring up GDP versus median
male income something bizarre happened
in the early 1970s that we should all be
talking about that almost nobody knows
about and one of the things that
happened was as the physics
if we came to an end a lot of physicists
will all right you see that graph mm-hmm
so geez explain to people they're just
listening so what it shows is from what
is it 1947 until about 1973 GDP and
median male income are going up in
lockstep they're almost perfectly
correlated mm-hm and then abruptly
median male income flatlines from about
1973 to 2000 2010 on this graph and GDP
keeps going up now that is people always
talk about the singularity when like we
will become one with the robots and AI
will take over this was the actual
singularity that happened and it
happened relatively unnoticed and that's
what began to de rain again median male
income is irrelevant it's just one
indicator that's particularly clean to
show you that that's that's when the
action happened my belief is that since
the early 70s very little in our society
has been progressing that's not true for
computers that's been like the big
bright spot it's not true for fracking
there's some innovations in imaging but
in general in an average room if you
subtract off the screens you can't get
definitely tell that that room didn't
exist in 1973 because we stopped growing
we got crazy because everything was
built on growth everything was a scheme
that became a Ponzi scheme when growth
ran out so we've sort of been hollowing
ourselves out from that time and getting
crazier and farther away from reality
and we have to actually figure out where
we are and my belief was that our
economy was almost completely created by
theoretical physics theoretical physics
underlies chemistry so the chemical
revolutions like plastics from from the
Graduate it gave us the semiconductor
from which we do our computing it give
us the world wide web which came out of
CERN it gave us telecommunications which
used the electromagnetic spectrum it
gives us medical imaging from tomography
we don't really appreciate the
theoretical physics has been the great
success story of our time and
theoretical physics community is the
intellectual SEAL Team six of the world
and we under pay them we there under
resource they're now completely
unethical because we've underpaid them
in and so Michael how so they won't talk
about their failures they don't talk
about who did what they're not fair and
decent because there's not enough
resources and so when resources get
scarce people become psychopathic and
like string theory is it's just an utter
failure that we can't discuss because
the baby boomers use that as well we're
making huge progress while they're
actually doing nothing I mean I don't
say they're doing nothing they weren't
making contact with physics they became
mathematicians like a bunch of soldiers
in generals who are playing war games
during peacetime there's it's related to
what they're supposed to be doing but
there was nothing for them to do so this
sort of went to the gym and ran on a
treadmill rather than actually running
marathons so we have a terrible
situation in that the the community that
powered our economy and gave us this
incredible power in the world through
like nuclear weapons and the rad lab at
MIT and whatnot has gone into decline
and it's very dangerous to restart
theoretical physics so it's been safe
because there's been nothing new that we
can use coming out of it my net my
belief now is that we have to talk about
a thousand-year solution to human life
with weaponized viruses with weaponized
nuclei I mean the amount of damage we
can do is astounding and that's going to
restart at some point since the nap is
now coming to an end like we're living
this is the end of the nap three months
ago we were all just leading la la you
know beautiful lives doing whatever we
were struggling we were you know
frustrated but we weren't even but when
she think this is not something that's
gonna we're gonna overcome and we're
going to get back to business as usual
December 2019 so assume that we do okay
okay so we come up with a killer
treatment we replenish all the masks we
have vaccines
we all just spent how long watching our
leaders tell us to shelter in place make
I mean we all went through this movie I
don't think like I'm watching
conversations about open borders changed
do you want here should we talk about
open borders today let's just keep doing
about escaping the planet and your
theory well ok because we we've taken
many deviations and why 84 30 all right
ok so this theory geometric unity
replaces space-time so thinking about a
fundamental theory is a newspaper story
it's who what sorry it's it's where when
which is space and time who what who
would be fermions that is matter
electrons quarks and what would be the
force that pushes them around how and
why how would be the equations and why
would be something called a Lagrangian
and what this does is to say that there
used to be two origins for for physics
there was space-time which Einstein gave
us and then there's this thing called SU
3 crusts u su 2 cross u 1 which comes
from nowhere that anyone knows what is
that well you and I are seeing each
other through photons photons are
scattering off us and being perceived in
by our eyes photons are associated with
electromagnetism and there is actually a
circle at every point in space-time so
here we are in space my fingers are up
here between us and I'm going to snap at
a particular instant at that point of
the snap there was a circle as there is
a point a circle and every other point
in space-time that we do not perceive
that generates all of electromagnetism
so call this the mysterious u1 we don't
know where this u1 comes from why is
there a hidden circle that generates the
electromagnetism that you and I use to
make visual contact that we use to send
electronic signals like our Wi-Fi not
only is there a circle there's also a
three-dimensional object called su 2 and
an 8 dimensional object called su 3
and effectively su2 generates the weak
force that's not quite right it's called
actually weak isospin
and su3 generates the strong force which
is sort of on the nose which is why the
protons in your body don't all push
apart given that they're positively
charged and like charges repel so why
don't you explode that's the strong
force and it comes out of something
called SU 3 we have two origin stories
one origin story is the story of space
and time the other origin story is the
story of SU 3 cross su 2 cross u 1 and
what I did was to get rid of the freedom
to choose the symmetries that generate
the personalities of the part of the
particles that make up this place and
then the question is okay I called it
the magic beans trade because if you
think about Jack and the Beanstalk Jack
gives away the family cow to get beans
which seems like the worst trade of all
time but the beans actually had much
more in them than was understood and so
Jack gets the better of the trade
because the beans allow him to do
something crazy so that's what I did I
gave away the freedom to choose the
symmetries to generate the particle
properties I tied my hands the way
Einstein would tie his hands and then I
tried to show that you could recover
these particle properties by trusting
that the theory would self assemble and
that's the hands drawing hands so the
ideas that I generated the fermions on
top of the space of all rulers and
protractors on top of the four to four
dimensions and the natural object which
would be called spinners or chimeric
spinners when perceived on the
four-dimensional object that is when you
pull back the information from the
second world that cut created into the
first from the pitch into the stands the
particle properties appear to be there
were more or less the right particle
properties of the particles that we see
now when I started this in the early 80s
we didn't know that neutrinos had mass
and so we thought that there might be
only 15 particles in a generation and my
stuff would only work if the number of
particles in generation was two to the N
so the joke when I was in college was I
sure hope that too
the fourth equals 15 now it can't be
because to the fourth is 16 but then
luckily for me neutrinos were found to
have mass and that sort of changed the
probability that there are 16 particles
so this is some weird thing to deal with
the fundamental incompatibility of the
two theories general relativity of
Einstein and quantum theory of Bohr and
Dirac in the 70s we found out that there
was a geometry that governed the board
Dirac part of the world called eros
Monte in geometry from Charles era
semana analyzation and Einstein did use
bernhard riemann a german mathematician
his geometries so my gambit and why it's
called geometric unity is that the two
branches of physics are derived from two
geometries so rather than saying it's
about quantizing geometry which is the
quantum field theory imperialist
perspective we mine Stein must submit to
bore the real issue is that there's a
fight between the parents that is
bernhard riemann and charles aricema now
we don't know those names nearly as well
and so my goal was to say is there any
world in which these two geometries and
the advantages of these two geometries
could be made to play together and in
general there isn't but there is one
case in which it works which is this
issue of natural spinners and so the
whole gambit was to say what if the
world is not a generic world but a very
natural and peculiar world where certain
games work that would not work in a
generic situation so what I tried to do
is to recover Einstein the way Einstein
tried to recover Newton from a more
fundamental theory and the
incompatibility is is that Einstein had
to compress something called the full
Riemann curvature tensor which is the
sort of measure of how warped something
is so he broke that beast that tells you
the warping of something in two pieces
he threw one of them out called the viol
curvature and then he adjusted the
properties of the other two that were
left to create general relativity
so my thing does that but it also has
another property called gauge invariance
in gauge invariance is the sort of cynic
wanton of the particle theory and this
is only possible in very limited
circumstances and the the gambit was
what if the world is in that tiny class
where this this game can work so it's
sort of a career suicide theory because
if it doesn't work this way you don't
really get anything in the end so you
know think about that exhaust vent in
the Death Star this tiny little
vulnerability and man you better hope
that thing goes in what are you trying
to do with this but by by releasing this
with this this discussion this video
that you're putting out are you hoping
that more people examine it and try to
actually implement it and then
ultimately this would be something that
allows people to to do what to do
revolutionized space try I don't know I
didn't know whether I wanted man to have
his own source code so I was invited
this is but you were serious about this
so this is like very close to you know I
love you came on this program and I said
it's straight we have to get off this
planet we made a joke about getting high
and all this stuff but I've always been
dead serious about what I'm saying now
if you ask me at a personal level I
started this for lots of personal
reasons I always thought that the idea
of wanting to go beyond Albert Einstein
was something everybody would grow up
wanting to - it didn't occur to me that
there was another thing that you would
want to do with your life like that that
seemed like the most natural thing in
the world I want to understand why we're
here well that means you're doing what
you're supposed to be doing yeah you
found your net I found my niche and and
then it started this kind of completely
bizarre thing because I was it was not a
good math student but I had to go to the
best place and so how does a b-minus
math student in high school go to
Harvard University with a master's
degree at 19 you know it's like just
sheer will cuz I was not a good math guy
so I just wilded into being I got myself
there I taught myself whatever it is
that I do I don't have an advisor which
is very unusual and I became intertwined
with this this theory and this theory
has been separating me also from people
I love in the world that I'm in I've
never known whether I'm crazy or whether
or not I have something I don't know
whether it unleashes power if it works
or it only unleashes destructive power
are you willing to have conversations
like debates with detractors or critics
of this I'm willing to have discussions
with constructive critics construct and
in fact I've done well because publicly
you have you said privately in fact
primarily yeah yeah I mean I've talked
to people like NEMA or Connie Hamed at
the Institute for Advanced Study who I
just think is fantastic there's another
guy named Louise alvarez gal May at the
Symons Institute it's not very hard for
the average person to follow but I think
it's not a bad person
I understand hear what I'm saying I
think would be incredibly valuable just
release it for the average everybody
yeah but I mean this conversation I know
you're saying it's not for the average
person but just to have it available to
everyone so if they want to they could
slowly go over it and try to understand
it bit by bit and put it together I
should talk about this I'm building I
shouldn't even say I'm building it there
is a fanatical community or rising
around the portal for what we're doing
that's different and there is a 24/7
discord server where people are talking
like if you're ever bored or lonely
these people are always on and or that
border lately it's not for you baby but
we've been trying to recruit a bunch of
artists because I believe that art is
part of the secret weaponry of pushing
out like I don't think you know how
crazy was when we did the hopf fibration
up here mm-hmm
it was like Close Encounters all these
artists start creating hop vibrations
like I went to Temecula in this guy
Neko Neko miners has a huge hopf
fibration in his backyard coming off of
this program it's like what people
tattoo your face on their arms right I'm
aware of all this stuff I just choose to
shut the door I'm I'm in there with them
yeah and do that good luck well cuz that
we're smaller that's true it is that too
but it's also a lot of what I do
requires me thinking on my own I have to
be by myself and spend a lot of time
staring off into space yep
yeah I in me too I but what I'm saying
is is that when it comes to people
following the story mm-hmm
artists and computer people are going to
help us push out aids - like can you
pull up Eric Weinstein org there's a
visualization that's sketched in the
door there's a portal in the website
there go okay so go down all right you
see that door no ya don't know why
that's the clip they took okay beyond
that there should be something okay
right here this is a picture of a fiber
bundle
and the path lifting property relative
to a connection so those floating planes
that was what generates electromagnetism
called horizontal subspaces and you're
actually looking at a gauge theory in
that picture and so what you're saying
is that what's valuable about the
artists getting on board with this is
that they can make a visual
interpretation of this that can be
cartoons like there's a guy named if you
had Grant Sanderson know he does a show
called three blue one brown which is
some of the best math videos you've ever
seen gorgeous stuff just sucks people in
and you're like you're learning
relatively hard math that somebody's
made visually beautiful this guy is a
national treasure and I'm hoping to get
grant on the program you know we've been
experimenting when we had Roger Penrose
in the program I said I'm not going to
talk to about quantum consciousness I'm
going to talk to you about twisters and
about your contributions to the field
and what my community did is they built
something called like the portal dot
wiki so if you bring up the portal dot
wiki there's an entire ecosystem that's
digesting what happens in our episodes
or the lay public a son of one of the
more amazing things about the internet
and about something like your podcast is
if you build it they will come you know
you have a bigger audience I will say
that I think I have the world's best
audience these guys like go to go to go
into episodes or how many episodes have
you had so far is it 28 yeah Oh Eric
Lewis by the way you should have in the
greatest pianist now playing in my
opinion so if you if you like if you go
to or go to the graph walls I love that
you're doing all this and yet you're
still interviewing porn stars and James
O'Keefe hey we want everybody yes I love
the hell with this cancellation yes yes
well not just that I just love that
you're just a curious person and
actually wants to communicate with
people on top of being this spaceman so
for example we have this graph wall tome
project where we start off with this
paragraph from Ed Witten if you go down
you'll see that they're figuring out how
the paragraph from Ed Witten fails over
into this wall that was chiseled in
Indiana limestone in Stony Brook in New
York which has all of these below that
so that's the paragraph that tries to
sum up the universe as we understood it
in the modern era in prose and I
recommend everyone read that and then if
you go down from that there's this plant
right right yeah go go there's a
clickable thing under that Neath that
graphic so for example this is the plan
for this sculpture that Jim Simon's the
world's greatest hedge fund manager paid
for and if you click on any one of these
things these ruins so it's like the
uncertainty Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle
my people are digesting everything that
we say everything that we point to and
helping each other
understand what goes on on my program so
that I don't have to spend all the time
in the shallow end Wow so like it's just
this is heavy [ __ ] oh my god but this is
what's interesting so I learned this
from you actually
you said cuz like I didn't think this
was a smart idea at all and people are
people are so eager to break into what's
next we want to spin our critic
rissalah's and become the butterfly that
we were meant for we're tired of being
caterpillars yes yeah I know you're
hearing five Meo DMT but that wasn't
when I was thinking no that it's I mean
I really think that that what you're
showing me that that is a branch of what
humanity is trying to do with creativity
with with curiosity with the the thirst
for innovation that's it well it's time
to go to the next level and we are
trying in the funniest part is like
brought to you by athletic greens and
there again good products yet this is
the funny thing about sponsorship you
see my grandfather was a Salesman and so
in a weird way I'm living a romantic
dream of connecting to my grandfather
who sold like used clothing and clothing
door-to-door he was a schemata salesman
and I've been astounded at how much I
enjoy all of the products that I'm
advertising like the sleep pad that
cools you so you don't wake up in a pool
of your own sweat unbelievable is great
I've lost 17 pounds through athletic
greens
well you've also stopped stuff in your
face with stuff you should need no only
athletic greens no the point yard you
know you know your face looks there yeah
it is but in part is because it I
figured out how to integrate it into a
program where intermittent fasting
started paying off this is a man we
could talk forever but I have to wrap
this up unfortunately but I'm gonna
watch your video and then I'm gonna
watch it hi I'm gonna do - okay [ __ ]
twice and I'm gonna try to figure it out
hey and Joe at some point let's just
hang out and I'd love to like just show
you exactly what it is tailor-made to
whatever questions without any worry
about yes about and let's do that
I can't wait and
just wanted to say thanks again for
everything but you do now only two
appearances on your show I haven't
called either of them in and thanks for
calling me on your show yeah - on your
show
yeah my show what's alright on my show
on my show yes yeah okay you got it
okay I owe you - you're the best thank
you sir you're the best bye everybody
one thing but Eric Weinstein org please
sign up for our mailing list so we can
find you after the yeah go get your mind
[ __ ] good luck good luck everybody
thank you brother all right bye
everybody stay safe